[Music]
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's Village Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
but I've been coffee free for four
months okay I gotta say that how could
everyone have someone out there for them
when there's more women than men like
I'm not saying you have to be submissive
to every old waste man walking around
I'm just saying that it would be
femininity would be in your nature
breaking it is to find somebody your
competing with that you'd like not just
if you're saying generation and that
likes the same things that you do going
out having fun then get out okay okay
then then get out then get out faster
Esther then get out I'm not here to get
canceled today most men want a woman
that has some degree of femininity where
they feel like they're taken care of
taking care of and lady like I'm
submissive and you'd be surprised
because I will say what I want to say
now and I'll say what I want to say with
my mind but my demeanor doesn't change
and I'm gonna look down on him because
at the end of the day whoever you're
with is a reflection of you what has
happened to society
like a three thousand dollar bag
foreign
[Applause]
before I start don't forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification Bell that way you're going
to be notified of my daily videos
um a couple quick announcements before
we start the show so the first is um
today we're doing a panel on body
positivity and personal trainers so half
of the people here are plus size body
positive models that sort of thing half
the people here you're all personal
trainers right okay
that's what they told him I'm just you
know double checking uh but a couple
announcements before we start the show
um first guys make sure you like the
video that is the most important metric
that YouTube uses to push out these live
streams I am so tired of this a like is
free we put on this whole production for
you I'm not expecting Super Chat don't
Super Chat whatever but if you're
watching for free like the video all
right come on also
um super chats we are going to take
today over what do you want to do king
25 20 20. he says twenty dollars
um so if you guys have a question for
the panel you can Super Chat we'll
probably read them every like uh like 20
to 30 minutes roughly
uh we also have two clips channels just
pearly clips and pearl daily
um so make sure you go subscribe to both
also guys we have four membership tiers
um the first tier lets you be a part of
the chat and how many likes to open up
the chat King
okay a thousand five hundred likes to
open up the chat also guys second tier
you get to be a part of our Discord
behind the scene Vlogs third tier um
which I do freestyle rap on so if you
want to see me freestyle I'm very good
second tier third tier connect with me
on social media and fourth here you get
a one-on-one call with me once a month
um make sure you subscribe to wife
school I'm learning how to dance this
weekend so if you want to see me do that
that'll probably be released in like a
week
um yeah I think that's nothing else is
new so I think we're okay so
um welcome to the show guys to start um
why don't we start with your name your
age and tell me
um
if you're a trainer a model like what is
your um
what what is your relation to like the
body positivity movement so starting
here and then go around my name is
Elisha I'm 24 and I'm a personal trainer
no and I
um
okay it wasn't sure I wasn't sure if you
modeled or something I know I'm not a no
no content creator I just exist okay
would you say you're a plus side like
like does do you do that in your brand
like plus size type stuff or no no no
I'm not really online I don't really
post to Instagram much okay I don't
really have a brand okay cool go ahead
I'm Sugar Puff and I'm an entertainment
presenter
and the way I actually started
being bothered about body positivity is
because
seem to just have people tweeted me and
I'm someone who respects people I love
people and that's that and um what else
I think that's it
um you said your age oh my age yeah you
know I don't want to discuss my age
that's personal it's a personal no how
do I look you tell me how old do I look
I want you to I want you to guess
uh late 20s to 30. like I'd say 28 to
35. okay I am 33 June the 13th okay so I
was right right yeah yeah yeah
[Music]
um go ahead
um I'm Pia Blossom and I'm a plus size
model and tick shocker and twitch
streamer and yeah that's my relation to
the body positivity Moon I'm 26 my
birthday was June 10th so also a fellow
redhead too absolutely which also helps
me very much in the plus size modeling
Community does it the runner is that
like sought after for modeling I don't
know yeah that's why a lot of uh blonde
girls
I think they chase me down to models
they dye the head Ginger because
obviously like when you have an agency
you have a quota that you want to paint
you want people to look different so
blonde girls will dare Ginger so they
match so if you're a natural it's it's
fun especially if you have long hair
would I be considered a ginger or my am
I not Ginger some people say that I have
I'm like a brunette other people say I
feel like people just say that like
sometimes people like oh my God just
strawberry blonde I'm like no I'm Ginger
just say I'm Ginger that's what I think
too but recently like the older I get
the more people say I'm not and I'm like
no I think you're a judge that's a
fellow Ginge great great it takes one to
know one
um go ahead yeah John Bernard uh content
creator uh on just on Instagram Tick
Tock YouTube so yeah from Australia down
here in London today looking forward to
the show 26. okay cool what how did you
what are you in London for
um I do I cover Sports uh like a sports
content creator and a bit of Comedy so
we just did the NBA Finals now in London
for Royal Ascot and we're doing
Wimbledon and uh the ashes for Cricket
so oh should be good fun cool cool go
ahead Hey so uh so my name is Kadeem
Moore I am 29 years of age and I am a
personal manager of yeah okay cool
um Alex
I'm Alex teens
yeah sorry the outlook.com sorry go
ahead what yeah no I'm Alex Dean some
personal trainer and the multiple
cirrhosis Warrior
um as well as a content creator as well
okay I preferred
okay
um welcome to the show so um first
question would you say health is a
priority to you
yeah 100 one thousand percent hundred
percent a thousand percent
in theory
yes no well it's a loaded question I can
say that health is a priority
um but I think I have unhealthy habits
that I'm not actively addressing okay
some of them I'm trying to like yeah the
progress is slow but it's there
um so yeah I'd say it's a it is a
priority but
um there are levels to it okay
what about you is Health a priority uh
yeah I think health is a complete
priority but I also don't think that
that totally relates to body positivity
okay if that makes sense okay
well explain that more
um so for me like health is a priority
um it's something I struggle with like I
struggle if I could press a button and
be like the healthiest weight in the
world of course I would push it in an
instant and I think anyone would be
lying if they said that they wouldn't
push that button to just be a healthy
way instantly and and have all these
things but um for me I struggle with it
and I don't think that that makes me a
bad person I don't think that means I
should think less of myself for that and
that's why I don't really associate that
with body positivity because I don't
hate myself for it even if it's
something I should aspire to okay I
think the girls had long answers there a
lot of the
immediately go 100
000 and then for the girls it's like ah
it's complicated it's long answer yeah I
just feel like is it a priority or is it
not a priority should be a
that's the reason why you wake up is the
reason why you get off your bed and walk
like you have to be healthy to be able
to live right
so who here
um would you would say is actively
trying to lose weight I am you are 100
you are yeah and what what have you guys
done is it like workout diet
yeah gym membership going to the gym
trying to be more consistent with it and
um making adjustments to eating habits
but also mindset okay what do you mean
by mindset
uh not seeing working out and you know
the steps towards prioritizing my health
which are admittedly quite difficult
some of them more than others as
punishment but seeing it as a reward I
think health is a reward for discipline
um and just loving yourself a little bit
more if you see it as punishment it
becomes something that you don't want to
do so yeah changing my mindset to reward
as opposed to punishment
um can could you turn up the headphones
a little bit I'm just having a hard time
hearing people
um
okay thank you
um okay so next question do you guys
think that body positivity promotes
healthiness
promotes health
depends what aspect they're looking at
from
um body positivity I know in the last
last week we had this discussion about
body positivity
and for me it's not about me being on a
big magazine or people like me being
promoted it's more about
um
like for example being accommodated for
in in public services and being
mistreated just because of the size now
I understand
um
I am the size I am
but at the end of the day people with
disabilities are also massage and people
how how do you know if I don't have a
hidden disability no one knows
so I'm just saying that's why to me body
positivity is important so that people
don't get mistreated
um I think that body positivity isn't
important in terms of mental health I
think there's a lot of people that
really hate themselves because of their
weight and I personally are like on my
socials get a lot of comments from
people saying that they are so happy to
see somebody my size comfortable with
themselves and happy and posing in
bikinis and things like that like all my
last Instagram posts have been me and
bikinis and I've got so many comments
from people being like wow I wish I
could wear that or I am gonna wear that
because you wore that and it makes me
feel like I can which I think some
people would take as a backgrounded
compliment but for me like as somebody
I'm trying to lose weight I'm trying to
be healthier because I know it's a
priority I know it's something I need to
do in my life but it's not my reality
right now like I'm not at my full health
I'm not the best I could possibly be but
I'm still I don't hate myself for that
and I think that
um the fat shaming movement and like
just being like these fat whales like
what the [__] are they doing
that's like a horrible culture
in the chat right now
I don't think that fat shaming helps
anyone lose weight and I think the way
we lose weight the way that I have been
there is I'm like I've gone online and
I've said like I want to lose weight and
I've helped myself accountability like
online really like yeah how much weight
have you lost so since I made that video
I've lost a stone okay that's great yeah
how much is a stone I I know I don't
know either
14 pounds I had like seven okay okay
yeah so I made a video because I wasn't
allowed down a slide that I wanted to go
down and that was like a moment for me
where I was like oh like I should be
allowed down this slide you know like
that was a moment where I felt like okay
I need to do something and it wasn't
because I felt shame or whatever it was
just like a bit of a like oh the average
person couldn't do this and I can't do
it yeah so I was like I need to lose
weight but it doesn't mean I don't
respect anyone less for being overweight
I understand what it's like to be
overweight I've been skinny I've been
overweight and I just I do think the
body positivity moment is important for
people to to like themselves and I think
the best way to lose weight is is by
liking yourself because you're doing
something good for yourself I actually
think that for me personally when I lost
weight it was because I didn't like
myself I didn't like the way I looked
and then it motivated me to lose weight
so I I actually it was funny because
when I did lose weight it was because
someone I mean they didn't bully me
directly but they were talking about how
they would never date a girl over 200
pounds and I was like no I'm over here I
thought he was cute so I was like no
well poor baby that's everybody for
everybody wow pearl baby does everything
for everybody if you're overweight
you're 30
um you're 30 as a woman
you're 30 less likely to go you need to
stop following statistics because you
got listen yeah you don't know the power
that big women have they Captivate men
I've seen it happen wow I've seen it
happen I'm not even joking you're also
six foot though I would say 200 pound on
you would like very different on five
foot four two hundred pounds
it's not to say like I know that's why
they were making fun of it they didn't
know how big I was at the time but but
no I
so it's still like I was still
overweight when I looked at like my
numbers so you know but it helped me
like I ended up losing like 30 pounds at
the time so and I never gained it back
so you seem like a person who's well
adjusted and quite mentally stable
though and I don't think that's the case
for everybody and I think when you tell
a lot of fat people like you're
overweight and that's disgusting they'll
come for you and if you don't comfy if
that's never been in your nature you're
never gonna do that well yeah but I
think the solution would be to maybe
stop comforting eating and like figure
something out so comforting is a coping
mechanism that people do that makes them
overweight you know so when you tell
someone like you're a fat cow they're
gonna be like Oh I'm sad so I'm gonna
come for you I think we change the
definition of body positivity because
what body positivity is
to me is numbers if you stop on a scale
and you see some numbers and then you
become a better version of yourself
every single day week or month and you
see numbers that improve that's a
positive result so body positive oh
sorry body positivity is becoming better
every day yeah but I feel like the
question was does body positivity
promote health and it's no it does yeah
exactly if you're if you're telling
people it's okay to be at a heavy weight
or okay to be obese and that's not
healthy
science it's not possible to be healthy
so to answer Pearl's question it doesn't
promote Health it doesn't put more
positivity
I would say it promotes mental health
not physical health no because that's
not the aim of the game but in terms of
mental health they make people forget
about themselves and likely to make good
choices about themselves I don't I just
would think the first step with mental
health is you're eating still because
they say sugar affects your brain I I
can pull up the research on it but I
know there's like negative mental health
effects from sugar this is true but I
think the point of body positivity is
not to say that it's okay to be fat and
to encourage people to be fat yeah like
I completely agree with you body
positivity does not necessarily promote
Health but it promotes not hating
yourself while you look like what you
look like don't waste a perfectly good
day inside feeling like you can't go to
that party or you you know you can't go
to work and being a shut-in because you
think people are gonna like take the
mick out of you because you're fat like
don't waste a perfectly good life
because you're not where you want to be
right now yeah like absolutely the body
positivity movement you know it should
um focus on health a little bit more but
I think for the individuals concerned
it's about not hating themselves and as
I said not punishing themselves for not
being where they want to be well she's
saying mental health wouldn't it be
better like in in Pearl's case to get
bullied and say hey you're getting a bit
pudgy you're getting a bit fat maybe
lose the weight and that'll promote
better mental health and you know you're
more comfortable with how you look yeah
you're feeling healthier I know I'm not
saying I'm fought bullying but it
forgets it to forget it to a better
place and a more comfortable with how
you look I I think it's uh it's the
right way to go especially when it comes
to your physique and how you look and
how do you say that I also think people
misplace body positivity with mental
positivity so what we're talking about
is mental positivity like what you just
explained is it's more in control of the
Mind than the body because when you
think about body positivity and that
we're promoting obesity or fat then it's
not positive there's more going into the
Negative Zone and statistically numbers
would show that
wouldn't you rather have someone that
pulls you aside and say hey I think
you're getting a little bit unhealthy or
hey you're putting on some weight maybe
you should hit the gym eat healthier I'd
like to have someone in my life like
that put me in check but like you know
if you're fat
I'm fat and I have no money
like I can see them at scale I can see
where my clothes don't fit like they
used to like you don't need someone to
tell you I don't know it's like it's
every Christmas at my grandma's house I
would just know there's that one
relative that if I came back fatter they
would say something to me and it kind of
motivated me every year because I'm like
I don't want that Aunt to you know but
you know you know if you're fat like and
sometimes people talk to fat people like
they're not self-aware like they they
know you know I know when I'm overweight
I know I've been incredibly good shape
before or like I was in drama school
where I was working out 12 hours a day
but like now I'm not and I'm fat and I'm
aware that I'm fat I don't even want to
tell me that I'm fat and bullying like I
mean for me it doesn't really work
because I just phase it out I mean I'm
like I've been online for a long time so
the things that people say don't affect
me but for most people bullying famously
does not work like it doesn't make me
people feel good it doesn't make them
work harder I don't know you guys not
speak I don't know what I have to say is
body positivity is to me is just really
accepting the way you look and and for
me ain't gonna lie I agree with uh to
some I do agree with a lot of what
you're saying and but when you when
being overweight has been an issue your
whole life and then people are also
people also make comments as an adult
like people have always just targeted
you for that and to me to be honest it
just scrambled my head and it wasn't
good for me
um so body positivity to me is basically
accepting the way you look and to be
honest I hated I wasn't happy with my
body Pearl I really wasn't and are you
happy with it now I am okay okay firstly
I'm like I am what I am but I make I
make conscious decisions like to eat
healthy things yeah and I'm also not
gonna lie and say I'm the most
healthiest because well last week you
were saying no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no but yeah but today is
about is we're here with personal
trainers yeah of course I love chicken
and tits and certain things
um and I can't help it me too by
moderation no no it's not about
moderation my way is old way but I
actually I get I can't have it in the
house otherwise I'll just eat the whole
box
my dad actually has cancer so in my
house everything is there's no processed
food at all and that's why it's just
literally you have to if you want to
drink drink you have to juice it
yourself if you want to get ice cream
you wanna you need to make it yourself
and it's full of coke with like boxes so
that's how it goes and then there's not
even a microwave at home as well so I
can't actually eat my food like
everything is basically in the best way
that I can cook
and what about the people out there who
are maybe in a similar situation to you
where they don't have access to
processed or unhealthy Foods at home but
they still seek those things when
they're out of the house what what would
you say to those people who actively
seek unhealthy food
I'd say my advice honestly would be
you don't want a heart attack you don't
want to die early
you want to survive you want to build
some memories you want to be a
grandmother or a grandpa
and it's important to actually think and
that's what I mean you need to
but wouldn't that be a better message
for the body positivity movement to say
rather than love yourself 100 like what
you just said you just hit because you
you could you could get canceled
nowadays for what sugar puffers okay but
no because it's like you know if like
lizzo comes out and says hey I'm I'm I
want to start losing weight all the fans
start coming for her and you know she
she just wants to better herself and get
healthy it's like yeah oh you're gonna
die soon
I don't think it's like that for me it's
literally I am not you know with myself
I am big I know I'm big but at the end
of the day I don't promote the reason
why I'm full body positivity it is
because people literally get mistreated
and I'm against that and especially with
how do you how do you think that how do
you think people get mistreated
um well I was 28 stunts I was at my
biggest
um now I'm 21 and and like I said I've
been eating healthy and I've actually
actively been trying yes I'm not on it
with the exercise but you could be
remember yes we could we could actually
actually what muscles you know actually
but that's why body positivity is
important the representation is
important now I understand what about
like smoking I mean like like what if we
wanted to normalize smoking and put
smoking on okay at the end of the day
smoking is literally yo it's a different
method smoking is
that's what smoking is and eating is
you're using your mouths you're using
your teeth and your taste buds are
working with smoking it's just well my
point is like normalizing something
that's I would say obesity yeah it's an
ill I mean I don't know if I'd go
I don't even think it's about
normalizing people just need to gain
some respect and know that people are
individuals now if you really want to
make an active difference if you guys
really want to make an active difference
when you see a big person you'd be like
come on man let's run or let's play a
game or let's do something like I'm
actively make a difference I want to
challenge you and as well to find me
like a body positivity movement that's
like eat junk do whatever you want yeah
that's not what it is yeah well it's not
promoting unhealthy no I I see girls do
it all the time they they do what I eat
in a day I just reacted to one the other
day it was like fourth oh my gosh yes
yes it's like fourth I counted 4 500
calories what's in yeah that's what I
said 4 500 calories in a day they do
like this is what I ate today as a fat
person yeah I think this is what see
that's yeah I'm against that and and I'm
like to me that's like like this is how
I smoked right I don't think we should
normalize it with that like for me
personally I would never show uh that
because I don't want to promote
unhealthy things in the same way that if
I smoked or Vaped I wouldn't show me
smoking or vaping on my page because
it's not something that I would be proud
of you know
um but like I I wouldn't support that
and I wouldn't call that the body
positive for what it means to me is
people just accepting themselves for who
they are
um wanting the best for themselves and I
don't think there's anything wrong with
that whether you're fat whether you're
skinny whether you're anorexic I think
that the body positivity movement
applies to you I think it's just
enjoying who you are and not letting
that if I thought too much about what I
look in a bikini I would never wear one
you know but I don't care so I just wear
one and I enjoy how I feel it I'm Pro
modesty you know what I mean yeah but I
mean you can have a modest bikini as
well
um
can I tell you what's wrong with the
with the world let's see what's wrong
with the world next statement go on okay
no no that is a big state if you can
tell us
oh my God
it's a pod this is what we're here to do
come on every everyone has an issue with
everyone everyone is like no they should
be like this they should be like that
everyone just needs to Simply mind their
own business and and when I say that I
don't mean in a bad way it's like for
example he like you said I don't know if
you said it did you say fat shaming
works is that what yeah okay so for
example fat shaming now imagine an
unhealthy person like me and I I mean I
try and be healthy yes but it is what it
is and I'm body positive because I I
honestly I've learned to love my body
now a pill and I'm sticking with that
but if I can lose weight I would as well
so
no no no no body positivity is all about
just accepting the way you look and
being happy and actually just be like
yeah this is we should always be trying
to get better no yes we can we should
always be trying to improve we can get
better it doesn't mean we can't be fly
and Trust ourselves I was just to your
point though Sugar Puff right you said
what's wrong with the world people are
saying you should live this way you
should live this way but it's not it's
say it's the body positivity movement
saying hey we should be comfortable as
this where realistically what if that's
killing you and then to your point as
well what Bill's saying if it's like
smoking smoking's an addiction you
brought up Comfort eating and that's how
people cope that's an addiction so it
it's you can treat it the same as
smoking when it promotes smoking as it's
all it's all sweet you know if you're
comfortable smoking and you're happy
smoking keep doing it we're not saying
you should live that way we're just
saying not even we it's not even what
you're just I think rational people are
saying if you're going to keep going
down that route you're probably going to
die you're going to lower your life
expectancy that's not okay so imagine
that's just the truth imagine look
you're a fit person you're fit you
exercise I can see that take care of
yourself in that
now imagine yeah
there's a big person and they're already
kind of suffering we know they're
unhealthy they're suffering they've got
knee problems they've got all sorts and
now they ain't even they're not even
surviving like they're finding it hard
and I'm talking about an unhealthy big
person and now you're saying ah you're
fat
never do that who does that I just wanna
people do and that's what I faced I have
faced that Pearl that's the sad thing I
faced it so when you I'm sorry obviously
you may not do that but people do that
I'd like to hear from the PT though I
wanna I wanna see how you respond to
this yeah
I have a cousin from Trinidad two weeks
ago that died from uh Cardiac Arrest due
to over
obesity
no she was one of the most comfortable
in our skin happiest person
make everyone laugh type of person
and she was definitely unbutted with
this entire world
would you call that body positivity
that's very sad and I'm sorry for your
loss
um no
you've just said relates to body
positivity
um I think that's incredibly unfortunate
what's happened but like do I think that
if people had been harsher on her she
would have lost the weight no I I don't
you know I don't think that's how it
works I don't think being mean to people
makes them lose weight yeah but talking
about body positivity
does it help
does talking to you nice help yeah I
think it is just to be kind to
themselves it's a long way I think it
just makes you comfortable to do the
same thing no but at the same time it
depends on what type of person you are
in it so depending on what makes you
tick you know I'm saying so some people
might respond to body shaming whereas
other people might like respond to some
a different type of method you know well
if it helped wouldn't you see most of
these influencers lose weight I mean I
am an influencer and I'm actively trying
to lose weight and I've documented it on
my platform and I've said how I've
struggled with it like I find it really
difficult what part of it do you
struggle with Phil uh for me like I so I
have a lot of problems related to when I
used to be quite thin I was very very
unhealthy
um and it meant that when I was thin
um I went to a so when I was like doing
acting and stuff I was in a theater
company where they would write all our
weights on the wall and it was always
like the goal not to be the biggest
person and everyone was skinny right so
I have a lot of problems around that
around weight around weighing myself
obsessively
and um because of that like I would just
restrict and binge and restrict and
binge and restrict and binge which um at
the time I was making myself sick so I
stayed skinny and then when I stopped
throwing up I got very fat because I
didn't break the patterns but I still
had the eating disorder of the
restricting binge and restricted bench
restrict and binge so when I stopped
throwing up I just gained all the weight
and that's still something I struggle
with like I restrict and restrict and
restrict and I feel very in control when
I restrict
um but then I will binge when I've had a
vulnerable moment or I've had an
argument with my boyfriend or something
in my life has gone wrong
um and I struggled with it but I think
the point is that across the board I
don't see plus size influencers that
have built their brand on body
positivity losing weight across the
board if anything I see them get fatter
and I see them drop dead and they're
like mid 30s because they're getting
rewarded you're getting paid to be a
plus-sized model your example why would
you want to lose weight if you're
getting paid to be in a plus size ad
yeah
for me if I'm plus size I'm Plus does
and sorry
um what was I going to say so we just
went out of went out of my mouth I'm
sorry I would say that there's also a
difference between like I'm a plus-sizer
if you lose weight yeah are you still
going to get plus size jobs
um so in terms of modeling yes uh but
right now I would say I'm at a weight
where I feel I feel unhealthy I can
still be on like overweight and feel
healthy I could still qualify for
plus-sized jobs based on my height and
things like that because I'm shorter and
curvier I'll still qualify and I still
worked in plus size when I was
technically like a healthy weight on
paper I was still Plus Size because I
had big boobs a big bum and I was short
and that's sort of what qualifies you
for plus-sized modeling so I did still
work in that then I've changed agencies
when I've uh if you were 120 pounds
would you still get plus size modeling
gigs no but I'd still be an influencer
and I'd still be very likable and I
think people would still follow my
contacts but we're just asking about the
plus size it's a hustle yeah and you're
you're like a boy but you don't just
build yourself just up nobody follow
someone just because they're like oh
this is a fat person I'm gonna follow
them like nobody's following test
holiday just because I mean apart from
the festival she wouldn't be famous if
she wasn't fat but you're in influence
influencing right so people follow you
because
why
I agree I would say that being
overweight being obese being fat is
oftentimes a hustle it can be a brand it
can be your identity just like being a
PT can be your identity one is
better than the other it's better for
the individual at the end of the day
in this economy they both make money
unfortunately
um and I would agree that being obese is
oftentimes incentivized especially if
we're talking about being an influencer
um like the the video that you mentioned
Earl about uh sort of someone who was
plus-sized doing or what I eat in a day
it would be very easy for a person like
that to secure a brand deal and start
advertising I don't know like corn
vegetarian sausages and they add that in
and say it's vegetarian so it's fine
it's healthy I'm not eating meat but
then they still eat like a six pack of
donuts in a day so I think what we're
talking about if we're talking about
obesity being incentivized
economically we're then talking about
essentially hustle culture and it is a
hustle it's just our opening for our
company to make more money
with that on saying when I made a video
saying I was gonna lose weight and it
went viral because I made I made a video
that was embarrassing and I said I
couldn't get down a slide and I was
really embarrassed I wanted to lose
weight and that did really well in the
algorithm and I got so many sponsorships
and companies emailing me with their
weight loss products because that is a
huge industry and I think that's far
bigger than anybody positivity or an
industry like the weight loss industry
is a huge thing I instantly had people
being like take our lollies take our
diet drinks take this take that give me
show it in your Tick Tock yeah I think
weight loss is a bigger industry than
than people being like I'm plus size and
it's cool
Fox would you rather take weight loss
products or stay as a plus size model
um I mean I don't think the weight loss
products work I don't think those
lollipops and I mean calorie deficit
works yeah
it sucks but it works like
um but I again I've said like I struggle
if I could press a button and just
both you know if uh one is both
detrimental to you which would you
rather not eating and you know maybe
even the products that are forcing into
a calorie deficit or staying at an
unhealthy weight what are you taking I
mean I I've already said like if I could
press a button and be a healthy weight
and have a healthy relationship with
food I would press it but that's just
not the reality for me and a lot of
other people and for me it's been a
grind and like I have been released it's
hard what's a solution like what's the
okay you say for It's A Grind for a lot
of people but what is the actual
solution of losing for me I
it's about body positivity is literally
accepting the way you are if I'm plus
size and that's why I tell people except
the way you look be happy you are the
way you are and you should really
embrace the way you are because when
you're not happy with yourself you don't
it affects you in the work you don't
have no confidence no self-esteem and
yeah you should be able to do anything
just beep and body positivity again I'm
gonna tell you again it's literally
accepting the way you look let me get a
little bit deep with it if someone wants
to die from obesity what would you tell
that person
honestly I'd say you know what you
should have eaten healthy and you should
have exercised you need already
I'm not telling any
common theme I've heard is is it just
accept how you are okay perfect wait
wait wait wait so this is the most
common thing I've heard would you guys
agree just accept how you are like to
like okay okay to like the way to like
yourself accept how you are don't don't
hate yourself for being but bear in mind
we're not trying to promote well I'm not
trying to promote promo unhealthiness if
you watch my tick tocks in my Instagram
I'm dancing I'm active even on my screen
if you're over if you're overweight and
you accept that then you're accepting
like a higher risk for diabetes you're
accepting a higher risk for early okay
you're accepting a higher risk I'm gonna
expect something like you have all these
okay okay so for example and and the
thing is like wait wait wait and so and
and the thing is like your families are
the ones that are gonna have to take
care of you if you can't take care of
yourself if you get too big so it like
then it's not just your problem it
becomes other people's problems more
comfortable to get the less your
checking numbers as well but I feel like
people were comfortable in their obesity
don't check it don't even check well and
the one thing I don't like is like
they'll say it's like unhealthy the way
you're
way every day when I
every day and I don't think that's like
they did studies and they found that the
people they didn't give them a diet or
anything but the people that would just
weighed themselves every single day lost
the most weight yep it's just a journey
like for me is honestly a journey and
that's why I just promote you know
because I know confidence is such a big
thing that's what I promote like body
positivity and it's not about obesity
it's just about literally I think I
think it does become about obesity when
it's like we're putting on well it's
like okay if an only fans model puts on
a thong and puts that on and says I'm
not promoting sexuality what well you
kind of are and so if you're oh if
you're overweight and you're in your
putting your body out there it's like
you are promoting Sugar Puff I'm gonna
pause you that so
um in the in the kindest way so if
someone is big are you saying that they
then do not deserve to be heard or seen
because they are big no I didn't say
that no so but are they leading with
their weight so yeah I would say I would
say if you're leading with your body
then yes you are leading with your wife
and how does someone so let's take lizzo
for example because she's like right in
the center of this topic because that is
I've never heard one of her songs
because her music doesn't appeal to me
but I know that she's right in the
center right body positivity her music
notwithstanding so let's take lize for
example a lot of people slate her
because she apparently leads with her
weight she wears revealing clothing and
I've seen on the other end of that
argument you've got people who compare
to say Rihanna or Beyonce they wear
similar clothing but their shape is very
different
I would argue that lizzo a is actually
potentially quite fit because she
performs for long periods of time which
maybe not fit maybe if it is the wrong
word
I haven't finished talking one second so
I would say that a she maybe has a lot
of stamina because she performs for a
long period of time I think she plays
the flute sometimes when she performs
and she dances and she sings that's a
lot to do in let's say 90 minutes all at
the same time there's a lot going on
there so I applaud her stamina and also
I could never be a Walmart lizzo at all
um so
I would say that with lizzo being at the
center of the body positive body
positivity discussion we should probably
look at her stamina a b we should say
that is she leading with her weight or
does she just exist as a fat person
I would say Adele did not lead with her
weight nobody really commented on
Adele's wait wait and Adele's weight
because she did not lead with that she
led with her Talent if you looked at her
Instagram it was her in long beautiful
dresses singing no one really talked
about it until she lost weight on the
other hand lizzo if you look at her
Instagram at damn near looks like corn
like it's her thong bikini she wore a
thong bikini thing to to a basketball
game with kids at it yeah in the name of
body positivity sometimes that's what we
mean okay that's Kelly Clarkson right I
think people people may have commented
on it because she didn't gain a lot of
weight people will comment but it's not
the main topic of discussion Kelly
Clarkson Clarkson Because she leads with
her Talent so you think lizzo dressing
the way she dresses yes let's say on
stage the same I don't agree with it the
same way I would say and only fans model
leads with her sexuality
like a girl that's on only fans and her
her Instagram looks like a cornhub
basically she is leading with her
sexuality how would you have Liz I dress
to not lead with her body
um and that's an open question I I would
say the the Thong thingies it's like a I
would say the all I would say basically
change your whole wardrobe look at I
don't know what Adele used to wear if
you look at any girl at a festival
nowadays very revealing clothing yeah so
that's that's probably the trend but
when Lisa is doing it it's getting
publicized it's everywhere it's been
pushed by media and then on top of that
she's proclaiming that she's happy at
that weight as well so she's also
leading with that she's responding to
criticism why is she getting criticism
because the majority of people don't
find that attractive and you go and you
guys can't a lot of people can't do
anything about that to the average
individual they don't find fat people
attracted to you maybe not I'm telling
you as a big person myself I'm not gonna
go out I get a lot of attention yeah and
I know a lot of big women that get
attention you're talking about a niche
no no no no
needs not Niche I don't know where you
got you could probably grew up with the
skinny skinny people but there's a mix
there's literally been a mixture
um for real that's how it's been I mean
there's always going to be a market for
it I mean there's categories for it
Sugar Puff but I'm saying that the
majority of people don't find it
attractive that's why they get criticism
and you can say it's whether they're
leading with their body or not but then
the day it's just she's in the public
life she's a she's okay I think it's
three I gotta find it but it's like
three out of five guys will eliminate
you based on your weight alone and they
deliminate you based on other things as
well which is completely too concerned
about it like a lot of guys would
eliminate me because I'm black or
because I'm maybe not tall enough or Too
Short like you know it is what it is
yeah but it's not variation
who said fat phobic no as in if you like
if it's just preference
yeah couldn't you argue that the best
dating advice for women is to lose
weight I would say that I have never
struggled regardless of my weight like I
I've been thin and I've been fat and I
have never ever like this is the biggest
like it's not the biggest because I've
lost a stone but it's almost the biggest
I've ever been and I've never struggled
in life I've always been called pretty
I've always got jobs that like are
around what I look like I've done well
online which a lot of people would argue
you have to be pretty to do
um and I've I've never been I can get
into the Mayfair clubs I can do
everything that I've ever wanted to do
and I've never felt like well I mean you
have youth on your side you're 26 right
and and why don't you argue you told me
a different show that you got more
attention when you were thinner yeah so
get attention now yeah but I've never I
mean the attention is a burden a lot of
the time for most women I burn it no no
women compete for attention no for me we
might as well get bbls they will get
surgery just to get attention but one of
my big goals is like so my audience has
split 50 50 male female on all of my
platforms my biggest goal is to go to
more women and so for at the moment I'm
trying to build on Facebook and when I
Target my ads I Target them women I tell
girly stories I tell gossipy things I
aim my twitch as like girly sleepover
Vibes like I don't want men because I
don't like that attention I have a
boyfriend I have a good life I don't
need men like yeah I mean again this
isn't but I'm not talking about you
personally but I think when we have
women getting extreme surgeries just to
get attention from men I think I think
we could say that women do want
attention I would just I would just say
I've seen the bbls have you seen them on
the planet I've worked as an actor I've
seen a lot of boob jobs I've seen a lot
of bbls I've seen it in modeling but
like what I would say is like as a
plus-sized person I've never felt like
discriminated against I've never felt
ugly because I was fat I've never been
told I was ugly because I was fat other
than like occasionally yeah but you know
what dogs I've never suffered for that
and so I would never give someone that
dating advice because it's never held me
back personally that's yeah personally
is the key there isn't it you personally
it hasn't held you back but then I guess
if we did a survey of of fat people fat
women
probably if we're being truthful being
fat has held them back at points whether
they know it or not right yeah I have a
question do you feel that I don't I've
never really actively dated so I can't
really say and also as I like to my own
point it has probably held me back
without my knowledge because there's the
scene and then there's the Unseen right
and you know there will be what some
people in post chat would call the
Liberals they would say that I have a
question on your side like there's yeah
there's the intersectionality part of it
that will go like well maybe you haven't
been declined jobs because you are
desirable in the market for other
reasons like size as much as as much as
you're comfortable in your skin if you
was to skip step on that skill and see
some alarm in numbers would you change
your lifestyle or would you continue
living the same lifestyle that you're
living right now I'm doing it yeah I eat
healthy and and I am very active I dance
like you see on my social media I'm not
actually trying to promote your
lifestyle I I'm trying to change my
Lifestyle by keeping it going and
actually going through the struggles and
literally keeping it going you are
talking to three fat people that none of
us here are sitting here being like
everyone should be our way and it's good
for us with actively saying like yeah we
need to lose weight we need to sort out
you know like but it's difficult I
commend you for trying to lose weight
and good on you good luck on the journey
right but can I just say it just depends
who you guys are deflecting the blame on
not just to you guys personally but the
fat in general it's not are you blaming
other people for calling you guys out or
do you want to take some personal
responsibility hey it's on me to lose
weight
I'm not delusional if someone says
you're big you're unhealthy I'm like I
just tell them look man I try and I'm
unhealthy and this is what it is and
that's why I say kindness matters so
much because you can actually be you can
influence someone to lose weight just by
being kind and the reason I just
thinking but I think
do you think I'm scared if that was true
then we would see
do you know what gyms do big muscle man
and skinny with the men that exercise
and they're fast and they can probably
poke yourself
but really when you're in the gym you're
meant to be like yeah come on you can do
it and not actually make someone a
certain way you want to hear some a
skill will actually tell you something
worse than a human you know that sorry a
scale will tell you something worse than
a human
why don't you say if someone says you're
fat it's the same thing as if you're
tall it's just a fact
Pearl it's true I don't want to get too
personal but I do have health issues and
that's why I that's why to encourage
myself I do the tick tock dancing I
actually go out I'm active I I went
surfing in Cornwall I um went Recycling
and plastic I actually do no that's my
way of exercise because when I go to the
gym and when I put too much I have other
issues and my body hurts and and my
obviously I started from China I'm
watching three trainers right here
do you spend money to do these things
you have to spend money to go Cornwall
okay all right 24 Trio for train spend
money for uh my issue is is the same way
you could spend money on uh nutrition
because one one day I will share my
story about my my I've a lot of things
like just and I was unfortunate within
life and that's why I always live a
positive life and I tell people be
healthy eat healthy exercise and that
and and I will share my story one day
but that's the thing I don't want to be
a story I don't want to be that person
he's big and now he's talking about this
he's talking about that no I'm not gonna
be that person because that's what
people think that's what people think a
plus-sized man is they're just basically
therefore there but no I actually want
to push myself I've got that push in
life and that's what I'm doing and and
along with that push because it was so
hard all my life that's why I spread
love and positivity because people were
just damn right nasty can you can I say
that can you say though conversations
like this are probably better than the
POS body positivity movement isn't it
when I talk about body positivity
no I was just saying it wouldn't you say
talking openly about it is better than
not just saying hey now I'm happy and
comfortable with my own way and I'm
positive I need to protect my mindset
but actually having we're civil we get
along Sugar Puff I'm like we're not
going at each other everything's okay
movement
do you know what it's just I see when I
look into the Pearl well sorry I need to
remember your name John John
when I look at people
I look into their eyes and I look at the
face expressions
and sometimes I see people and I see and
it's with any size or any shape or
anybody I see sometimes I see people
have had a hard life and they're trying
to keep it going in their smile
and that's why I don't see people in
their way or the way they look because
people have more to them and the thing
is I'm all about like I don't think
you're answering his question though no
but that's look Okay the reason how the
way I'm answering it is what I'm saying
is I see people's soul and that's why
for me way whether you're skinny fat
small I literally see people sold and
the words and and the crazy thing is
I'm usually right like I can I can look
at someone and that's why sometimes when
I know people have when I know when I
can tell people have just they go
through stuff every day day to day
I'm not gonna lie that's that's what
makes me laugh that's what makes me
happy because I want to encourage but
what conversation's more productive I
think that for us this is a productive
conversation so we're three people that
have come here we know what the topic is
we know what we're talking about and
we're willing to sit here on a challenge
with a million subscribers and talk
about it I think most fat people
wouldn't do that you know I don't think
I don't think a lot of people even plus
size models I know personally would not
be comfortable to sit here and defend
the body positivity movement and so it's
easy for me to say well yeah this is a
great conversation we're going on really
well but do I think that this would make
some of my fat friends break down and
cry because they don't want to
acknowledge the fact that
um they're having a terrible time but
maybe maybe they'll cry and then start
to lose weight sometimes it starts
with do a breakup she did not eat that's
how sad she was she lost the win all
right all right all right
I I I think it could be the first step
you know I'm I'm serious when the guys
at my work they had this conversation
about a women over 200 whatever were so
fat
I went in the bathroom and I cried and
then I ran a marathon and then I lost it
right yeah and I I just think like
instead of getting emotional about it we
should think about Solutions
[Music]
I'm gonna say I'm not going to lose
sleep if someone is crying uh when
people are just telling the truth
say what you want to say because you're
scared you're gonna hurt someone's
feelings you know at the end of the day
if it's the truth and someone is
overweight to where it's unhealthy
they've got to deal with the reality you
kind of say oh let's just protect them
people have different coping mechanisms
as well
would you rather your friend tell you or
would you rather a skill tell you
I just think it's a very personal thing
where like if my boyfriend came to me
and like me and my brother have had this
conversation where I've been like I want
to be healthier I need you to help me
and he's like okay well like my
boyfriend has a sweet tooth but he's a
very skinny guy and like he's like okay
I won't eat cake around you I don't want
to tempt you you know and we've had
those conversations but they're very
vulnerable conversations of people very
close to you I don't think that we
should be telling people in general
and I think this is the problem I think
as a society we're too loud
I've never had a conversation with like
a 70 or 80 year old and you this is what
I mean when I go to my grandma's house
at Christmas and they're just like yeah
you're fat I don't I don't tell my
friends that they're fat but I tell them
look it's unhealthy I'm a stranger on
the street but I I think in your Social
Circle at least somebody should tell I
have a question if someone if
um you know person a is overweight and
people whether it's strangers or their
nearest and dearest tell them in
whatever way kindness first we hope that
they are unhealthy
and that you know I love you you're
unhealthy you need to get into the gym
and I'll even come with you that person
cries
but then harms themselves maybe on our
lives themself yeah
a is that the person or the people who
told them to lose weight is that their
fault and B if not is that just
Darwinism is that like yeah like the
weakest just go because
you're looking at a very minor example
yeah okay that doesn't happen I wasn't
giving an example that was a
hypothetical if that was to happen for
example I've got a fat mate how many
times have we heard this I've got a fat
friend I I get I love the fat but I've
got a fat I've got a fat friend shout
out to calca when he gets overweight we
pull him aside we don't pull them aside
we actually our mates as a group
together mate you're getting party time
to lose weight what's the New Year's
resolution this year giving up maltesers
again like we're just we dream up it's
to a point if he's gonna go and harm
himself again that's not on that's not
on the group of friends that a joke
really have banter with him and
encouraging him to lose weight that's
just again Paul said society's gone too
soft I think is the case of that why
don't you wouldn't you say they're
harming themselves either way because if
you die of a heart attack at 35 you're
gonna have the same outcome I mean even
now there there's a new there's like an
epidemic of people between the ages of
25 and 30 getting cancer I think it's
obviously I basically call this cancer I
mean there was a big ad in London for a
long time instead of basically causes
cancer a lot of people have a problem
with it I didn't have a problem with it
I'm asking at the time but it's true uh
basically causes cancer no one is
denying that but that doesn't stop me so
um one of my tweets I had recently was I
tweeted myself in a bikini and I said
stop waiting to lose weight to get in a
bikini and just go and enjoy yourself
with your friends in the sun no no I
think you should wait I think you should
because
I think I think I like feeling like my
bikini is earned yeah but yeah
when I was thinner I was less inclined
to wear one because I was more insecure
when I was fatter I was less likely to
wear one too and I I think that's like
as the world should be does that mean
you could use it I think you should show
no I think you know you should be modest
in that regard yeah I think you show off
things you're proud of and I don't think
you should be proud of being overweight
I'm proud of being overweight but I
wouldn't say that I shouldn't go in a
bikini with my friends at this like
watch I should just sit on and read a
book while I wait for them you know I
just want to enjoy my life oh there's
one pieces I have a question
um I think I look good you know I've
checked my Instagram peer Blossom
underscore X I think I look good in a
bikini now wait you see earlier when you
said that you're not at that part of
your life where you're ready to do
anything about it like why is that what
could get you there no I feel ready I'm
sorry I'm working on at the moment I
just struggle with it it's just it's
hard for me okay come over here five I
work out five days a week I will no I
find it easier having a boyfriend
because he supports 11AM yes every day
right we're talking about the topic here
um
with using weird fat but there's also a
fat called visceral fat so there's fat
and visceral fat do you are you aware of
what visceral fat is the fat around the
heart no the arteries so if you was to
find out your visceral fat is at an
alarm in stage would you continue to
live the life you're living
and this is this is the thing we should
be more aware of the word the word
weight I I
I'm not
we shouldn't be using the red weight so
much but yeah the other numbers that's
way more important we're talking about
body fat muscle mass percentage uh water
percentage visceral fat which is one of
the most dangerous fat that you can
approach
so if you was to find out where your
visceral fat is at an alarming stage you
would not be sitting here talking about
body positivity you guys get you guys
and get yourself
so I have like severe asthma which was
caused by covet so I've had a lot of
Health tests done and in general I'm
pretty healthy like in terms of my heart
and what's going on with me like I'm
pretty healthy a lot of that is youth I
think that if I was older and um like at
the same BM I am I'm at it might be more
difficult you know if visceral fat is
that uh I have no idea but I'm sure that
my doctor does and they didn't have any
problem with my my heart in general
um because I had all those tests done
recently because you know my asthma like
stopped me breathing because I'm
allergic to my pet guinea pigs it's a
whole thing
um but yeah
yeah Tess and I'm recently
as I get older I'm
as I reach my 30 things I'm 26 now
um things will get harder to shift and
I'd rather do something about it now
um and as I said before I don't think I
don't think anything I just don't think
you can be healthy at your size I don't
think that anybody is kidding themselves
by that though like I don't think that
anybody my size
you were healthy in terms of like what
my doctor said and like I I wasn't told
what does that mean what did you say I
would prefer hair for my nutritionist
maybe
I don't know much about that but like
obviously like I mean I have serious
asthma so like I was in hospital and I
had a lot of chats and things like that
about my General Health and on that
continually caused by food too because I
have issues with adults nutritionists
will give two different results yeah I
think it's um for me
I'm gonna Kid myself and be like I'm at
my full health yeah like no I'm very
overweight like I'm not joking myself
about that I would like to lose weight
as I said if I could press a button and
be skinny I just think that's what the
body parts if like if body positivity
was really like body positive it would
be about losing weight but I just think
it's not about losing weight it's about
being content I think for them is
actually mental positivity because body
positivity is about who are being
confident keeping us in mind
when you talk about body positivity all
I hear is about mental things like being
confident having a scene mental well
he's getting the gist but what's wrong
with it positivity yeah yeah
you can call yourself
healthy but you know in reality the
reality is yeah
nobody said we're healthy or I'm healthy
or we know we have to eat healthy
actually they said that she's healthy
she said that she said a doctor said she
probably means did you mean the fact
that you ain't got a big illness
would you say obesity is unhealthy yeah
yes well then I don't know if anyone
would disagree with that and I think to
the point around uh visceral fat and
smoking so now in the UK at least if you
want to buy a packet of cigarettes or
tobacco you've got loads of like images
of lungs and what it does and like all
sorts of scary images that are supposed
to put people off I wonder if we were to
have the same sorts of images around
visceral fat yeah maybe actual people of
actual images of obese people although
that could be problematic to some
um on unhealthy food if that would have
a deterrent effect so let's start
showing fat people on chocolates and
stuff yeah well I wonder if it would I
mean if you're showing fat people like
if you've just got an image of a fat
person that's probably remember the
commercials they used to do about
smoking where it's like smoking will
kill you why don't they have that for
obesity when 60 of the population is
overweight or obese are you sure you're
good why not we should why don't we
start a campaign okay
we're the right groups
you know I produce it myself one of the
key things that we're establishing here
though is that all three overweight
people here are not saying that you
shouldn't be healthy we're not saying
that you should be obese we're all
saying yes it's about to obese yes we
should get better yes I mean I'm saying
that because of my youth I don't have
high blood pressure I don't have any of
those things wrong with me doesn't mean
that in 20 years it worked but I think
but but I think I would love to hear
that message more from influencers like
yourself yeah rather than being content
with the way you look rather than
talking about wearing a bikini
I think the better better solution is is
what you're doing which is to be an
example of losing weight and being
healthy but actually healthy at the same
time I don't think that you should wait
to enjoy yourself because of your weight
I don't think you should wait to wear a
bikini I don't think you should wait to
do these things I don't think you should
dislike yourself or not wear the dress
you want to wear or not go somewhere you
want to go because of your way or not
have pictures I've met people who don't
have that picture no one's saying that
but I do think that when you're obese
that should be your first priority so I
I do think maybe instead of going
wearing a dress and going out on the
town you should go to the gym and stuff
that's a motive why are you wearing a
bikini yeah why are you going to the
club in a revealing dress are you
enjoying yourself at the club what like
what why are you wearing a bikini
because I wanted to go have fun with my
friends
fun wear a bikini is
n't for wearing a bikini be any
different from like a mid-sized or slim
person where you are supposed to wear I
would say nine out of ten women wear a
bikini one for attention from males uh
to to woo another guy probably why do
they wear revealing dresses at clubs I
would say it's mainly for attention I
mean they keep they say it's whatever
sales but I would say it's mainly for
attention and it's um I don't say it's
like I wear a bikini because I feel
comfortable in a bikini I wear a bikini
because I just want to impress my
friends I'd say nine times out of ten
you're trying to impress another guy or
you know whoever you're attracted to
what's wrong with the fat woman trying
to and men want a short arms because I
just think I just think it's unrealistic
for them to to think that a lot of
people are finding them attractive when
majority wouldn't if is that fair to say
no I'm not the majority of women I can't
speak for all men but I would say
majority of blokes wouldn't find fat
women in a bikini attractive
I'm just just Five Guys in
season six so who here would disqualify
a girl from dating her just based on her
weight yeah 100 so you wouldn't you
would so uh that ain't confident who's
not confident yeah king would you
would you disqual would you disqualify a
girl based on her weight
if he was fat
yeah
but but I have dated a bigger guy before
but yeah
so that's that's a hundred percent yeah
we just have Five Guys
small sample size I'm sorry
statistically some of my numbers so no
matter what if I'm with you on your
numbers then right
it's about shape right if she had a tiny
waist she was Buxom and she had large
thighs and a big button you would be
like yeah she's rocking that but if she
was rounder like more of an apple shape
then you'd be like yeah you need I'd say
this tears I'd say this tears for sure I
mean if you look at Nicki Minaj you go
oh yeah okay I could see only bikini
wouldn't mind that she's probably a bit
larger than the average individual but
an obese woman in a bikini probably not
everyone's cup of tea would you go up
sir and ask her what her what the fat
around her heart is like if she looks
like I would judge it based on how she
looks if she looks unhealthy probably
disqualifies her is that that's probably
Fair how long have you been a personal
trainer can I ask yeah how long have you
been how long yeah uh I'm just qualified
but it probably since 2018 yeah so three
of my late his Instagram posts and me
and a bikini in different bikinis and
they all did absolutely fine they have
lots of comments telling me how great I
look and I think I look great in them
you know and I'm an obese one so do your
kids do your clients trust you
do your clients trust you I think they
would yeah and what's the biggest client
you've had
um like the biggest way I'd say it's I'm
only trying or trained guys but just I
would say the average probably like 100
110 kilos I'm sorry that you listen you
need to do more personal training
because until you make a big person lose
but you're like a big big so big
purpose how could think about it man
come on yeah personal trainer their job
is to help people
80 of fat people regain it within five
years
I don't want to come but for real a
personal trainer is all about actually
helping and encouraging others and you
need to actually set an example and be
the example
but you see with the personal trainers
here how long do you spend with your
clan an hour if that an hour if that so
if any more time you want twice a week
three times a week so then how am I
going to control your life or make you
lose weight or motivate you if you're
not even taking committing yourself to
losing weight yourself personally and a
lot of women a lot of women
there are so many personal trainers that
I know wait say that again I'm saying a
lot of women just get personal trainers
as a counselor they go there tell them
all their problems they're not really
there to lose weight wait a minute
so I mean it's it's what he's saying is
it's on the individual you have to have
some responsibility the personal trainer
can't babysit you yeah hey what are you
eating monitoring they can encourage you
all they want then how do other personal
trainers help other big big people lose
proper weight myself
I think if there's less of a body
positivity movement like more things
that attitude needs to be promoted by
personal trainers in general not but in
general because when you go to a gym
what is it it's personal trainers that
are meant to be saying you're in a gym
well done you've made it you usually sit
at home eating whatever you're in the
gym let me help you but no it's the
opposite
those sorry those are pts which
structure
because if I started training you I
already motivated you from the starter
start training and if every let's just
say week or two you are checking your
numbers and every week or two you're
actually getting results from these
numbers that's motivating you to come to
the gym more to be there more to eat
healthier to do more is because you are
getting better every single day
it has nothing to do with the PT it has
nothing to do with how how much you show
up it's about what you're doing behind
my back it's always it's all up to you
you are your own motivation and when I
show you these numbers and you see every
two weeks or a month I listen I dropped
4 kg in me let's just say one month that
should motivate you to do more great
it's all in the numbers has nothing to
do with mental health and all lifestyle
and all this and all that [__] no
it's all in your numbers that's just
that's just my opinion and there's only
when I show that to my clients they're
motivated to do more they're motivated
to lose more it's because they see that
they're improving themselves by showing
up and doing what they have to do and
showing that consistency that's all
that's important to be honest
you know what yeah you keep on dropping
this word motivation I hear motivation a
lot in this podcast but a lot of people
lose motivation very quickly and it's
what it is is actually discipline a
discipline to get you to your goals a
lot of people are not disciplined a lot
of people are not consistent in their
cause either yeah a lot of people are
consistently doing nonsense so it's just
like stay on point but how are you gonna
do it unless you're like stuck in your
ways you need to break the cycle you
know and a lot of people aren't breaking
their Circle you're saying the earlier
run it was hard for you to do it but for
whatever reason like we need to break
the spiral so how are we going to do
that like just like our concert today we
just say Beyonce if you want to go to a
beer and say concert bad and you don't
have the money you will find this money
somewhere somehow
so just go to this concept priorities
priorities
I actually really wanted to go back you
will find a way so it's the same way you
find out where to lose weight
it's going wrong
I'm here here where it's going wrong is
you're getting uh rewarded almost on
social media you're saying oh comments
found me attractive uh it's okay but in
reality
like I said before nine nine out of ten
people would say it's unattractive and I
think you guys could agree with that but
I again as I said like I've never
struggled I've never felt unattractive
in my life I've never gotten to a club
that is strict about like Mayfair clubs
I've always got in doesn't matter what I
am I've always felt attractive and been
attractive in my life like I've never
struggled is that is that scene are you
all right are you waiting until
like are you going to continue
I don't want to say continue getting to
where you are but you're gonna stay
comfortable until no I'm trying to say
that I just think it's a criteria of
what you think attractive is I'm trying
to you're telling yourself you're
attractive and you're in you're putting
the criteria as I get into Mayfair clubs
and exclusive parties and whatnot but I
if their General consensus of what is
attractive of what men find beautiful in
women then I'm not saying to your face
that you probably wouldn't tick that but
I'm just saying at your current weight
probably not but what I would say is
that like I am actively trying to lose
weight but that has nothing to do with
how attractive I am and that is not
something that motivates me yes
I'm trying to lose weight because of how
attractive I think other people I'm not
saying why but I'm saying your weight
absolutely does dictate how attractive
you are okay yeah like fine but that's
not a motivator for me losing weight
it's not a motivation it's just whether
you're attractive or not that's what
people said
she's saying weight has a direct impact
on how attractive you are and I think if
all attention I mean you just talked
about the attention you got from
Instagram so if all attention was taken
from you tomorrow I think it would
motivate you to lose weight but but the
problem is even overweight women still
get attention because of Instagram
social media and all of the stuff that
like normalizes obesity like a hundred
years ago everybody was in shape so if
you were overweight like you would be
shamed everybody would say something you
were the outcast but now it's normal
that's because
people have different Beauty in their
eyes like some people they would look at
someone and and wait would it matter
it's their real Beauty so that's why
you've seen the big girl with the fake
guy or the big guy I only believe it
because people actually only believe it
when the men with all the options start
picking big women
but you'll see a heart check with a
really rich ugly guy yeah because you've
got money instead
name me one Hollywood a-lister that's
gone out with a morbidly obese woman
can't think of one not one I'm sorry
they got a public profile
because there are loads of secret tub
Chasers let me tell you that a lot of
Secrets
women value commitment so secret doesn't
count that's like saying oh I'm this
person's side chick it doesn't count
like it doesn't it doesn't matter so if
we're talking about uh being attractive
to men yep
we could sit here and all jab appear or
person X and say yeah but you're not
attractive to men because you're fat a
she's already got a boyfriend
B
I would say that the goal posts always
change for women because even if a
person X were to lose weight maybe they
I don't know have dark hair and Men
Prefer Blondes and then she's got to
bleach her hair and she is too short but
there's nothing she can do about her
height so her dating paw is always going
to be that little bit smaller preference
is bred by variation look at all of the
variation between like the people in
this room there are some people let's
talk about now women and being attracted
to men there are people like who would
prefer you John over person being and
that's fine right like if you are not
attractive to person a you're going to
be attractive to someone else but the
criteria will always change the goal
posts will always move especially for
women because we know that there's a
huge market around like beauty standards
the GoPro Smith for men I mean I'm not
probably just about to say that as well
you've got to have a high status to a
command an attractive woman but to that
point I mean Peter I'm glad you found
love it's great for you and you've got a
boyfriend but would you think if you
were healthier maybe skinnier that you
would find someone other than your
boyfriend that's a bit more attractive a
bit more higher status as a higher
paying job I'm just trying to yeah do
you think if you were more
attractive due to your weight that you
would find someone better than your
current boyfriend or is that too
personal to ask someone no I think that
my boyfriend is great my boyfriend's
very kind he's very generous he pays for
everything takes me on holiday we
literally just came back from holiday
paid for everything
he's no he's a wife
why you got these bikini pictures but no
boyfriend on your Instagram because he
so he owns a business and he doesn't
want my brand he doesn't want it he
doesn't which is too like I'm on a red
flagpole but he doesn't it's his choice
like I've offered but um he doesn't want
his brand associated with mine just in
case I get canceled or something I don't
know is that true love uh what does that
mean
he doesn't want his brand associated
with you but you guys because he has a
couple you guys are a couple yeah but he
has a company his private stuff is all
associated with me like our Facebooks
and things like that that just our
friends can see but um not like publicly
because they didn't if you didn't answer
my question do you think if you were
skinnier you could have got a more
attractive boyfriend no I love my
boyfriend and I think he's incredibly
attractive and I think he's incredibly
attracted to me
so you you didn't think if you're
skinnier you wouldn't mind they like
each other they find each other
on Netflix
but let's let's take it away from you so
it's not a person yeah yeah yeah so like
let's just say the average chick do you
think she has more options at 250 pounds
I'm sorry I don't know the conversion of
that or 120 pounds which is like
uh skinny chick I think it depends on
her figure personally
what do you think I think it depends on
the girl for me personally I prefer my
boyfriend that I have now that I'm
overweight that I did my boyfriend I had
when I was skinny sorry Lewis well again
we're taking this away we're taking this
we're taking this away from you away
from you so just the average chick being
OB ese or being scared
but how I had more attention when I was
that way but also women need to pick
correctly and a lot of women pick wrong
it doesn't matter you can have the most
attractive one in the world and she will
still pick a [__] [__] like it
just you know what I mean like it
doesn't matter you have to pick
correctly and a lot of that's to do with
your self-worth and self-esteem which
for me doesn't correlate to my weight
well and I'm not discrediting what
you're saying about picking correctly my
only point is that the girl thinner will
have more options
has so many options just being a woman
if you go on Tinder doesn't matter if
you like test holiday can go on uh like
you're you're right Tinder right now and
she'll have more sex but not commitment
from the men that we want and we can see
this because women are can there are
more and more women that are going to be
single and childless they're predicting
half of us are going to be single and
childless meaning that the men are not
living up to what the women want
just remember it's not personal to you
just um
yeah I I don't take it personally but
like I don't
yeah in terms of that question that's a
very big question I don't know what the
answer is but I don't think any woman
struggles for attention well yeah but
attention isn't commitment in
relationships which is what women want
but like who I've never met a woman that
really genuinely struggles to get a boy
to date her like it what uh I would say
ugly chicks I've met a lot of struggle
I've met a lot of men that struggle to
get women
a boy but not the boy they want I would
say that's really common and even to to
your point I say I I from my experience
guys that are going out or committed to
larger women I'm saying like fat chicks
they they are usually not the man in the
relationship does that make sense I
don't think they're wearing the pants
nine times out of ten
actually I think they are wearing their
pants because they're black they're
helping the big person do things like
help them with their to help them
no but that would make sense though
because if you're if you're helping her
do things then she's wearing the pants
because in a traditional relationship
she's helping him not the other one but
that's the thing it's again
it's done to each individual
relationship some people motivate
themselves like you like you you
mentioned a few of the big stories that
people are promoting eating but then
there are so many stories where people
met each other and they lost to wait
together there's so many there's a
hundreds and I'm saying I wish the body
positivity movement would promote those
yeah instead of lizzo I wish they would
promote weight loss instead of people
that are content being big I think if we
really wanted to be positive about it
that's what we would promote and I'm
sorry that is just not the consensus and
what we see in the media but Pearl it's
not
the media has a narrative right but it's
almost like a lot some of the plus size
things that I see written on magazines
or when I say I can't relate to it yeah
because I'm like no it's not like but
when I when I see the leaders of the
movement start to lose weight and talk
about eating healthy and actually doing
the work like that's that's when I would
agree with you but I just don't think
it's pot like the way lizzo's going like
who do we think yeah who's the leaders
and it's always healthy if you watch it
she's healthy and she's constantly
exercising pull up the food right now
she posts
no I I just did reactions to these they
are not but I feel like what most people
don't like about body positivity or the
people at the top of these movements is
they're they're claiming that they're a
victim
you know what I mean they're saying I
you know I need to pay for two plane
tickets or you know I get treated
differently well that's all on you you
have the power to change that so 100
it's it you you can't it's just again
like we said earlier
people aren't always overweight because
they air like you need to remember a lot
of people are overweight because they're
ill or something happened and that's how
they overweight so that's why you can't
discriminate discriminate people they're
not discriminating but I'm saying you've
got to take the victimhood away from fat
people the general fat person that
doesn't have a disease that doesn't have
you know uh pre-existing condition
they're they're ultimately just feet
people get nasty and that's what happens
and that's that
okay you don't need to feel sorry for
them but just don't be nice it's 100 in
your control but we'll say well shame
guys for being short having little let's
say short man syndrome he's got a this
he's got it and nobody and nobody has
sympathy for men but for some reason
like when it's body positivity now we're
supposed to have sympathy when that's in
your control
when God's guys relax honestly relax
we're just educated right so it's tough
to live a life you just have to things
you have to say nothing exactly
seriously everyone's real name
I'm gonna let him go though so go ahead
if all starts you where you live where
do you live me yeah
um at the moment I live in a six yeah my
answer to you you live in your body
first
oh before you live in your house oh I
live in my body okay that's true when
you get up in the morning yeah yeah and
you have breakfast yeah you have the
opportunity to make your diet better
right Lisa do you know I eat for
breakfast
it's the same way you take care of your
body you live here first as much as you
try to take care of everything outside
of your body is the same way you could
take care of yours because that's where
you live first you know I don't know you
live anywhere else I don't know anyone
who eats porridge I actually eat that
and I'm now I'm used to it I'm just
saying generally yeah I have porridge
every day as well the same way you can
take everything else in your life you
can and you have the opportunities like
I said I keep stating guys I am doing
those things no this is not to you this
is generally okay
I don't think anybody here is arguing
that nobody here is saying you should be
obese you should eat unhealthily you
should be okay with eating unhealthily
my argument is like you should not hold
yourself back for being overweight you
should just live your life I would say
you can't not hold yourself back by
being overweight I would say if you are
overweight you are holding yourself back
you're going to get less opportunities
you're not going to have as long of a
life you're going to have health
problems you're going to have mental
health problems there is no way to not
hold yourself because of your weight all
of those things and still say you can
still want to do those things you can
still want to be healthy in the same way
I want to be healthier and I'm trying to
lose weight but like I still won't stop
myself doing things now because of my
way I won't feel insecure because my
weight I won't stop myself your weight
will stop you from doing certain things
like like I'm even just first thing that
comes to my head can I ask you why
why won't you stop
stop
doing things from
oh well I enjoy doing because like why
would I not go to the beach with my
friends and enjoy my summer and like
Just Dance
what was that sorry what's more
important your health or your friends
I'm still working on my health but like
what I'm saying is I'm not gonna stop
myself living my life because I'm
overweight now I'm not gonna put my life
on pause because I'm by the way I don't
think anyone should you don't need to
put your life on pause though you just
have to commit yourself yeah yeah but
you say that like um I shouldn't be
posting bikini photos on Instagram and I
shouldn't be doing this and I shouldn't
be in it nobody's saying at the beach
Pals just said that no I would say that
saying that I would say well I am going
to do that and I'm still gonna lose
weight and I'm still gonna try and be
healthy I'm gonna work on my issues but
like I'm I'm also gonna live my life and
do all the things that I want to do and
I think that everybody overweight
watching this should do the same thing
and when you like the reason why when a
big person looks good and make them feel
good because that is the first step of
them being like do you know what I look
good I feel good I can actually do this
I can lose weight that's why I
compliment big women when they look good
and when they're feeling themselves I
don't think they can look good when most
men will nobody wait wait wait where
most men will disqualify you just for
your weight alone everyone deserves to
feel beautiful and they should have that
right I think I think everybody deserves
to be beautiful and I think most women
will be beautiful they're in shape if
you're in shape you're the top like 20
of women nowadays but different people
have different Beauty in their eyes per
like I said beauty is objective yeah
like your opinion like everyone in this
room they don't find big people
attractive that's fine that's
understandable because we all have lacks
and dislikes but you need to know that
it's your eyes and your eyes but some
people no people are different you know
the ideal scenario is Sugar Puff there's
two fat people meet each other and lose
weight together that if that that's true
love that's true that's what happens I
love you I know loads of people like
that because it's the struggle and when
you have support I can imagine I can see
why they lose weight it's because they
have that support and and things that
they find hard that they can't do to
lose weight they get that support and
they help one another but there's many
supports and guidance out there you it's
up to you to seek it poor health charges
interest though doesn't it like I think
I'm not here to like uphold the body
positivity movement because personally I
could like couldn't give a crap about it
but um like what I will say is poor
health charges interest if you you know
you don't go to the gym once you have a
rest day or a cheat day and then it
becomes a habit and then all of a sudden
your back hurts or your ankles are
swollen and now you find it even harder
to work out because you have mobility
issues like the issues just pile that's
another thing and I think that's
something that a lot of people who are
unhealthy unhealthily big that's like a
really ugly truth it's the horrible
underbelly if you can even call it that
oh that's such a huge pun sorry um yeah
it's like the it's the really nasty
underbelly of obesity like having
um bed sores isn't there that program
like my 600 pound life or whatever you
see people they can't get out of bed
they didn't wake up like that they just
ignored very small signs your body
Whispers to you you choose to ignore it
then it starts to shout at you exactly
but there is no amount of body
positivity there is no amount of lizzo
there's no amount of test holiday yeah
it's going to take you out of that
reality you have to do it yourself
like anyone who is is big and is you
know on their journey to to health is
acutely aware of that it's the people
who are as we're saying are like nastily
comfortable
um in very poor health not just I'm not
talking about Aesthetics I'm talking
about poor health yeah those people are
the people who desperately need help and
I wonder if it's just like a drug
addiction where you sort of need to be
pushed into something to help you some
sort of program I don't know how program
yeah like is it is it something that
needs rehab I don't know maybe dangerous
I think we should have fat camp 100 we
have we have rehab for drug addicts I'm
not gonna lie like I would go to a fat
camp 100 I think that would help me
being
um immersed in it why don't we encourage
it in society like why don't why aren't
there weight limits at clubs like there
is a like theme parks because it's
safety like that I I understand what I'm
saying like like smoking why aren't we
on why aren't we encouraging people to
lose weight
non-nutritionist because the worst thing
is going out you're in a mosh pit it's
dark it's sweaty it's hot in there and
why it's so tight is because there's a
couple of fat people there and it's just
like where should they be if not at the
at the club 24 hours so they should they
shouldn't party yeah
if they want I mean if it's going to
contribute to them burning calories go
for gold but their priority should be
the health I'm making a joke but their
priority should be their health yeah
maybe we should have uh separate fat
parties for fat people fat beaches for
for fat people like we have noodle
speeches no but I think they're mixing
them
wait wait the better solution is to go
to the gym like nutrition when I was
trying to lose weight I really didn't go
out I didn't drink I didn't like spend a
lot of time out because I wanted to lose
weight like that was the priority I
actually stayed um at one of a Plaza's
hotel in Antigua what and and it's
called the catamaran it's called the
catamaran and they actually promote like
they've got a beat on it so they promote
walking
um they they they made it plus size
friendly how if you codex if you want to
exercise you could so there are places
out there which yeah they are for plus
size but they also promote being active
so there are places actually that exist
and I've been there and you know being
overweight more time it's not even be
you being active or not it's what you're
eating you know that right yeah why do
people go to doctors I'm not
nutritionists because nutritionists
don't have the I guess
validation from society that doctors
have I think that's hundreds of years
we've been told to go to doctors doctors
have been the people you go to for
medical issues I think that's quite a
new thing no that's actually wrong
correct me then you
sorry a nutritionist would actually tell
you where you're going wrong versus a
doctor that will give you a prescription
with that nutritional nutritionist ID
person that would actually design a
program for you tell you where your
numbers are and no
what program is going to be personalized
for you to help you lose that weight
instead of going to add doctor that
would be okay you're healthy it's fine
you don't have a health condition and
versus the nutritionist will tell you
your statistical sorry your statistics
numbers that's going to help you to
improve that's fine but you haven't
corrected me because
um that wasn't okay so in the case that
you know in Pierre's case if the doctor
tells you that you're you know you've
got a full bill of health yeah and not
just not even you just in general I'd
questions if you told me that I'd be
like
yeah would you agree with that oh if
personally like I can make this back
myself if my doctor told me that I have
a full bill of health I would call
someone because I'd be deeply concerned
about like his his methods because I
know that I'm not healthy do you think
that's happening a lot with doctors then
yeah is not going to give you a
nutrition program well full bullet
Health was yeah good good blood pressure
cholesterol is down you know and Asthma
is okay whatever you whatever you were
saying but you know if you're obviously
are basing a doctor say no it's all good
keep going keep going how are you going
you don't have to just do that I don't
think doctors would say that though I
just you said it earlier yeah my doctor
tell me to lose weight that doesn't mean
I shouldn't lose weight it just means
that it wasn't the core issue of my
asthma like when I was having
conversations with them and they were
looking at my blood pressure and my
cholesterol and things like that they
were like okay all good don't worry
about it your vitals are fine like these
things are okay for now and I even
acknowledge that like a lot of that is
probably to do with the fact that I'm
young and that when I'm older did you
see a BMI it's easy you mentioned a BMI
of your office what's the percentage
muscle mass these things yeah so I
didn't have my BMI measured at the
doctors but I have had it measured
because they do it when they do your
birth control sorry Pearl for mentioning
birth control around you uh ban it ban
it
um but like I have talked about my and
when I talked about my BMI and when I
had my birth control done with a nurse
um they actually did the NHS has like um
healthy plans and I have like the NHS
app which I've been using to
um help track my weight loss and things
like that
um along with like my fitness pal and
stuff but um the NHS app and they also
put me on like a little healthy eating
thing at the time when I had my birth
control because that was when they went
to my BMI and things like that so there
are things on the NHS that doctors and
that was a nurse actually that gave me
those things
um but yeah there are things available
to you you don't need to see it and
that's why I'm seeing it's more
accessible but a nutritionist will put
together a plan a program to help you
lose weight I don't think doctors want
you to be healthy
because they make money off of you being
unhealthy well the NHS you think makes
money off of us
what was the whole last three years and
it just makes money selling medicine to
everyone not just big people to everyone
that's their business yeah but when
sixty percent of the population is
overweight there's a lot of medicine you
can sell well there'd always be a
problem it remember it's the food that
we're eating the food that's not the
chemicals that are in the food
whatever the these lands that we see in
the air the fall that we eat from the
plastic cup that we drink that's true
but at the end of the day there's always
somebody that's accomplished it even
with all of those factors and yeah
that's why we always encourage people to
lose weight and and yeah we don't say no
don't lose weight but like I said
celebrate big people but also be like
nah that's unhealthy yeah I feel like
that's the same point that we've just
we've been repeating the same point is
that like these two things can exist at
the same time you know like we can exist
and be happy with ourselves and live our
lives and we can also want to be
healthier especially what I've done is
I've Incorporated being active in my
life that's what is that's what I see
that's my exercise actually traveling
doing things going through new
experiences if I have to climb I climb
if I have to swim I swim that's my way
of Healthy Living living life I'm just
saying that a lot of people say that oh
um they're struggle and struggles and I
struggle when there are people out here
that have the tools to give you what you
need to lose weight but bear in mind the
first people they run to is it or they
run to either doctors or they run to
Social Media a lot of people a lot of
people who are qualified to give you the
exact information that you need to help
you get to where you need to be they
give you the numbers that you need to
have to give you now the motivation and
concern to get you to where you need to
be and there are people out there that's
qualified to do these things
instead of seeking
instead of seeking information from the
wrong people we need to fight the right
people to give you that support there
are people out there to give you that
a lot of big people have that want to
just make that card and that suffer they
have mobility issues or their ankle or
something it's too late and there's
something I know something no there is
no no no no no
they have to do a lot like this I know
someone with no legs that's jacked
there they have I swear to God this
dude's in better shape than me yeah yeah
yeah
I'm like what's our song that I'm like
nobody has
excuse the upper body they don't have
legs they need to use their literally
the whole body or they can't move so
they have no option so if they're okay
if you have ankle issues okay three
personal trainers ankle issues what
would you do how would you how would you
get them wait to lose weight but even
that doctor will tell you to lose weight
I told him to go on a bike yeah get on
the get on a Mobility black cross train
or something no no but they can't nobody
Cycles
if their floor is not leveled it can
affect you just want to give you an
example of someone in a wheelchair
getting jacked a kind of wheelchair has
to take an elevator up the space but it
doesn't even have to be exercised yeah
if you have anger problem doesn't even
have anything to do with physical
especially if it's from a weed problem
it's just tired you have to die a
thought to lose weight there are means
and ways Alex you I think I remember you
saying that you're an MS Warrior yeah
like there are circumstances that can be
overcome really difficult ones that are
far more profound I would say than like
me personally just like getting fat
because of poor habits it's not enough
for me to just be in bed and saying oh
I've had a hard life but what about when
like what about when the problems affect
other people
like health problems like when you can't
do things with your kids yeah 100 when
your family has to take care of you
because you're sick but people don't see
that far you know
sad City Comfort no but it's cool yeah
you don't see that far I do think
anybody is advocating for that though I
think that's very sad yeah it's sad but
how do you stop from getting there do
you lean into body positivity or do you
go the other Wing thank you very much it
depends whatever benefits you as a
person and but see that that's the
problem right there it's about that's
what benefits me and that's the problem
with body positivity it's about me me me
me it's about the way I feel it's not
just me wait it's about what I want to
do it's about I don't care what I look
like to the beach to everyone else I
want to feel good like it's all about me
and nobody else yeah but I've been in
that context was it's what you respond
to so if you as a person respond to the
body positivity moment that makes for me
personally feeling good about myself is
the thing that makes me want to lose
weight when I like myself I treat myself
better I eat better I'm more likely to
have get on better with my friends but I
just think if that was true people I
think if that was true you wouldn't be
overweight yeah but like like I know
you've lost 10 pounds but you know 10
pounds I haven't always felt like that
yeah and you can feel a certain way but
the results speak for themselves but I
don't like myself when I was skinny I
didn't like it it's a it's not about
like I love myself I love myself I love
myself it's what you respond to in terms
of if if positivity is what motivates
you great I got to a point where I was
like okay I need to think positively
about this I'm saying let's look at
results
but let's look at let's look at the
results of body positivity and we see
and we see the the women that lead it
get worse and worse every year and you
would argue the the people that you're
giving as an example is leading it I
don't agree with what they do I don't
agree with what test holiday does I
don't agree
um but for me personally I respond
better to positive influence positive if
I had a personal trainer that was like
you fat [__] lose weight I wouldn't go
back if I had a personal trainer it was
like you're doing so great this is
fantastic you've lost two pounds like
I'd go back you know and it depends what
you respond and I think if I see that as
a result like if I saw those results for
you like I might think more of it but
it's just tough because you're saying
body positivity is such a good thing and
you're a plus size model but your
results are you're still overweight
I mean I'm in the process of that but I
haven't always been in favor of body
positivity Point Blank I would say I was
more about body neutrality which is
basically just not caring and just doing
whatever and that was how I thought for
a long time right but body neutrality is
selfish because everybody else has to
deal with your poor decisions even if
you're just neutral like liking the way
you look and saying I'm gonna accept
myself as is everybody else has to deal
with your decisions because either
you're gonna have health issues and the
taxpayers have to deal with it the
doctors have to deal with it your family
has to take care of you and it's not
fair to everyone else around you even on
planes like it's not fair to the people
next to you who didn't make that
decision and now you know you're
invading their space again I can't speak
for those people because that's not my
issue I've never not fit in a plane seat
I've never had a health issue because of
my weight specifically
movement in general yeah but I'm like
someone who's saying like being content
in general is selfish because everybody
else has to deal with this issues but
being content with yourself doesn't mean
that you shouldn't want to be better it
just means that you shouldn't have what
else what else is what else is content
content as happy as is I think it just
means that you shouldn't hate yourself
like if I'm if I'm content with my money
I'm not gonna make more money if I'm
discontent with my money then I'm going
to make I think that's a great example
I'm very content with the amount of
money I make would I like to still make
more fantastic yeah I would but you're
not going to take steps to make more
money if you're content with the amount
of money in general we're getting into
semantics they want me if we're using
the word content like I agree with you
know like being content because that you
are you're stationary you're happy no
more progress but I think the point here
is that you can enjoy your day you can
go to the beach with your friends if you
want to and actually enjoy a day on the
beach with your friends without the fact
that you are maybe not your healthiest
weight or not your best shape and
allowing that to taint your day even
even at the beach like it's going to
take your whether anyone says anything
to you or not it's going to taint your
day you're not going to be able to do
the same things your In-Shape friends
are gonna do
uh there's no there's no way you guys
are going to have the same Mobility as
someone as the as the trainers here if
you guys go surfing if you go tubing
like you're not going to be able to do
the same thing
so while while it might not affect you
now it might be you're young maybe it'll
affect you later but at some point life
is going to hit you and that's why I
promote eating healthy and actually
trying your bestie actually yeah I'm not
talking about you I'm talking about the
movement
is different the people different it's
not different people see different
narratives it depends what you're
reading what you're seeing and with a
lot of things there's a lot of confusion
it's like people just want to confuse
you and they want people to have
discussions like this and they want
people to fight but really if you speak
to real people you get real opinions
that's how it is I don't think it's I
think it's simple I think it's if you're
fat you're unhealthy if you're not fat
you're healthy it should be as simple as
that really that shouldn't be like oh
it's confusing you know there's going to
be people like I said there's a small
amount a small percentage of people
that you know I probably do have
conditions and and whatnot but at the
end of the day if you're fat you can
acknowledge that you're unhealthy and
you've all agreed that you want to
better yourself and and start eating
healthier whether it's training as well
so I mean yeah you can keep trying to
individualize it but at the end of the
day it's it's very it's night and day
and it's also you need to see where a
lot of people are obese the poor areas
if you look at obesity rates it's the
poor areas and what are what are the
import areas not great shops for food
it's all cheap stuff it's not good for
you are you saying the Obesity rates are
higher in in like third world countries
not third world countries but just
generally like for example I'm saying
like that I'm just thinking if your
premise is true if we're going to say
it's about wealth then I would imagine
we would see in poorer countries they
would be fatter than in richer countries
okay for example in England
um there's Iceland's it's It's Like A
pounder meal you can get a pound ready
meal you can get um nuggets and chips
I need you to answer my initial question
though so so in third world countries
they're fatter than in the Western
countries in In There Are Places this
Fiji in general I know homeless people
with abs
there are places in the world there
where it is pouring there and they're
big
on average people in poorer countries oh
not in average no it's in the UK the
western side correct so I'm saying I
don't think it's a wealthy thing okay
yeah I think it's a poor like I mean
we're the fattest in America
you know yeah but then within America
what groups of people just to get deeper
on that point I don't know if I really
have an opinion or a strong one on this
but within America or even if we take
London are we saying then the poorer
people within those places are more
likely to be unhealthy obese than the
Richer people I think it's it's uh
easier for them to get obese yeah if
you're living on like a minimum wage
income and you're gonna get fast food
all the time yeah that's probably the
case in America but there's a large
portion of the population
30 according to the CDC 38 States Plus
Puerto Rico have obesity rates above 30
percent the 10 states and territories
with the lowest obesity rates our
District of Columbia Hawaii Colorado
Massachusetts California Florida New
Jersey Washington Vermont and New York
um sounds like a choice then yeah we
have to Overlay that with um have like I
don't know income household
Colorado's low obesity rate can be
attributed to culture and lifestyle many
residents enjoy outdoor activities such
as hiking as well as conscious of eating
whole nutrient dense foods for their own
well-being and this is surprising to me
West Virginia is the most obese state
with an obesity rate of 40 percent West
Virginia
also has a type 2 diabetes diabetes at
15.7 wow 15.7 percent of West Virginia
has Type 2 diabetes what can I ask when
would be the point of okay I've got to
make a change
when you have a health problem and when
for example
um I when I thought that I'm
pre-diabetic I instantly started
literally our consciously was like no
I'm not gonna eat no crisps I'm not
gonna eat no chocolate no I'm gonna get
diabetes and I'm gonna mess my life up
so I I reversed it and I started
drinking more water so that anything bad
flushes out and started having vinegar
and just doing random things when you
get told uh if you keep going this way
you might die that's when you're gonna
make it sweet I just listened to you and
I feel and I felt moved I think that's
what I mean when that's when I took it
seriously when I was told by the doctor
and that's a part of me being active
basically because I don't want to have
high blood pressure I don't want to have
diabetes so it's because I can't see at
the back I feel like I can't I don't and
I was thinking I wish we sat him there I
can't see him that someone's promoted
one social media like this you will be a
happier place but for me it was when I
couldn't go down a slide I was at like a
amusement thing and I couldn't get on a
slide that my friends went down and that
was really embarrassing for me like I
was like oh ah like I am not the average
person anymore and that was a moment at
which I was like oh I want to be able to
do these things and so and I made a
video because I I knew that that would
hold me accountable on my social media
well I also think that it's a negative
consequence which kind of It kind of you
might not call it bullying but that's
that's a negative consequence and it
seemed to have worked because now you're
trying to lose weight it's not from a
person though and it doesn't mean I
don't like myself
yeah it's a wake-up call and that's why
I was saying sometimes bullying is a
wake-up call I don't think bullying is
that Amusement that amusement park owner
was bullying you saying it was a safety
thing
I'm gonna Read Super chats for uh one
second
um okay Mr B no they're not they're not
bad well okay this
this damn another uh term to add body
nature reality SMH Haka police redheads
man found cutie slapping but doesn't
respect her hey you most obese people
are addicts dopamine is the real driver
of addiction food addiction is the only
uh one where you still have to use your
drug to survive difficult to overcome
but it can be done find healthy dopamine
triggers
a scout in a Bradley I find Health sexy
not too skinny not too big a crackhead
is not sexy But Lizzy isn't lizzo isn't
either
Hakata police
um uh fats will tap dance around
accountability all night Mr B they're
not acting like ladies I'm not taking
accountability uh the same way uni
doesn't guarantee a job personal
trainers don't guarantee losing weight
uh Dr David Baker and the spirit of the
body positivity movement I'd like to
announce the start of the chain smoking
positivity movement the drinking bleach
positivity movement and the put a
shotgun in your mouth with your toe on
the trigger positivity movement I love
the body positivity movement almost as
much as I love chain smoke the chain
smoking body part the chain smoking
positivity movement the drinking bleach
positivity movement and the shotgun in
mouth toe on trigger positivity movement
um hokkada police welcome to cope cast
um Ricky a donation just get just to
give a shout out to Pia family Doug MPA
everything yeah ever everything you get
paid for everything you get paid for
should require sacrifice plus size
models don't have to sacrifice anything
that's the problem I have to go to work
every day I don't want to but I do it
hashtag lazy whales Doug MPA we I'm
sorry we we harpoon whales over here Pia
a whale attacked Pearl and we cannot let
that happen again it was attack it was
used it used to be that big girls had to
have a good attitude to counter their
weight but those days are gone Doug MPA
um body positivity really became a
movement after the the war in Iraq
started soldiers were coming back
missing limbs it was supposed to be made
for a woman or a man to wear a biking
Miss to wear a biking missing an arm or
a leg whales hijacked the movement
selfish whales
um what do you think about this Super
Chat everything you get should
everything that you pay get paid for
should require sacrifice plus size
models you don't have to sacrifice
anything that's the problem I have to go
to work every day and I don't want to do
it but I do it I agree with that I think
it's if what are you sacrificing for
your plus size model is a I could be a
plus size model starting tomorrow I'll
just start putting on weight get pudgy
yeah
I could make steps towards becoming a
plus-sized model maybe I guess a bit of
cosmetic surgery but just get fat and
then maybe sign up
so you just need to just stick to it
like I I feel actually hot I feel hot
but anyone could anyone be a pleasure no
no yeah maybe if I lost somewhere I'll
even be hard but I feel happy with the
way I look but if you put on weight
because people are so used to looking at
you you might not be happy with yourself
because you might be like oh my God and
then you need to learn to love it that's
not the question is it
was model sacrifice anything so I would
respond to that a comment by saying that
person sounds more like they have a
problem with capitalism than anything
else because why are you doing a job you
don't enjoy I really love my job I make
content all day I do brand deals I
stream on Twitch I have a great time
with my life and I enjoy my modeling
um none of that feels like a sacrifice
to me none of my jobs have ever felt
before that I worked in sales again I
really enjoyed that I like I I never
felt like my life was a chore
um and it sounds more like you have an
issue with that and no I don't think
anyone could be a plus size model I need
you you need a specific look regardless
and including being plus size to be a
plus size model you still need to have
an hourglass shape I disagree you can't
be an apple it doesn't work
in the past
I'll let you go I would say every job
has a form of sacrifice so that person
that's in the Super Chat in Works nine
to five doesn't want to go has to go
Paul being a content creator puts in
hours probably doesn't have can
socialize as much misses out on that
doesn't see friends a model an actual
tomorrow
probably has to starve herself sometimes
uh has to work rigorous hours travel a
lot there's sacrifice what's they do are
insane workouts are crazy what does a
plus size model sacrifice why do they
need why do you need people to be
unhappy to earn their money
is that in in work when you work you
sacrifice something when you strive for
something you have to sacrifice
something what is a plus size model
sacrifice well I'm in a room with three
pts and no one's saying that the plus
size model is sacrificing her health
despite the fact that we've spent the
last hour talking about health so she's
sacrificing her you think that should be
a job then
hold the money I'm not gonna let you put
a spin on that I didn't say that that
should be you said they're sacrificing
their health no but they are sacrifice
we just discussed that if a person is
plus size and they're maintaining their
plus size like brand their identity
they're sacrificing their health because
being fat becomes a hustle now that is
the direction and I I I I guess it's not
the best way to put it a sacrifice but
it's more that like in order to get
money and jobs you should have to do
something hard and getting fat is easy
that's the easy way out and now we're
paying people to do the easy thing it's
like if I go to an NBA game and I see
below average NBA or basketball players
it's kind of like why are they there but
yeah yeah
wait wait wait wait wait but now we have
we we go to modeling shows and we have
below average bodies being modeled when
before that was like the epitome of
perfection but it's just not a skilled a
particularly skilled preference it's a
model of skilled profession I just said
that it isn't it
clearly skilled like if we're competing
we miss any point it's just for that
confidence
as well as maintaining a workout
it's not a Top Model nobody Tyra Banks
you on how to be the best
that's the company just looking for a
market to make more money but you agreed
you said that uh what what person
getting fat is easy agree yeah so
there's no there's no sacrifice but your
health is just sacrifice I don't
understand how we're not agreeing on
that point despite
that's negative so that is so your
health is a sacrifice yeah yeah yeah
you're you're willingly shortening your
life for money
it's
air source
can I just tell you let you know I've um
taught children swimming I was a dance
teacher
um like everything I've done even me
doing my entertainment work is active
full of activism and that's how I live
my life to be active because I know when
I go to gym and when I kind of push
myself I fall apart and I go backwards
because then I'm in pain for months and
I'm in bed that's what starts happening
right but like the whole point is do
plus size models and maybe not sacrifice
is it hard to become a plus size model
number four wait wait wait wait and
before like I don't know if you've ever
seen like the what I eat in a day from a
Victoria's Secret model before they were
plus size like their workouts it's hard
it was it required a lot of sacrifice
but it required a lot of sacrifice but
the what those damn what does Victoria
Secrets girls have done to a lot of
women is damaged them as well because
they tried being super fit like that
although they had no potential some of
them actually started taking drugs to
look it looked like a Victoria Secret
model I said three percent of the
population is underway or it's like five
percent I don't know but I think a lot
of people's obesity is also related to
taking a lot of this rubbish weight loss
tablets and being sold be skinny be this
be that and they have it and they they
get to be wrong because a lot of the
Obesity is from remember we have the 90s
was how the noise was into actually I
think that's a victim mentality like I
just think that I don't even think
that a lot of rubbish was put in food a
lot of rubbish was put in food but at
the end of the day people are fat
because of their choices
that's it Point Blank period it's not
because of the food it's not because of
the water because there's ways around
all of this and with with the internet
with the internet there's no reason you
can educate yourself
what you were saying Paul though like
your initial point I just think it's
such a non-issue because one there just
aren't that many plus size models there
are a few but like in general I find
people a lot of the comments I get are
like oh my gosh thank you so much for
modeling like particularly when I
modeled a fitness wear for a bit I did a
plus size Fitness weight
um range for a well-known brand and
people were like oh this is great
because I actually know what it's going
to look like on me now as a fat person
who wants to go to the gym which is why
everyone wants is these fat people to go
to the gym what was the most well-known
fashion show
and what happened
they started putting plus size models on
the runway and everyone hated it oh
correct so we're seeing some of the
biggest fashion brands incorporate this
yeah
I just I just don't think you could say
it's a non-issue when I see them on the
cover of magazines all the time I see
them in store they even make mannequins
that are pluses
why why is there a market for plus size
now why do you guys think there's a mask
now okay what's the motive mind market
for plus size what exactly models or
plus size clothing like when you go on
online shopping and you see a bigger
person modeling the clothing why why is
that because fat people have to wear
clothes no it's because you think it's
nice when
when you basically buy the clothes the
fitting is wrong and you know a big
person didn't make it because the car is
usually funny yeah and it's not like
that with with normal clothes so okay
because fat people have to wear clothes
but that's that's the body positivity
movement because you're now encouraging
people to be at that weight because you
can buy clothes and look like this
whereas if I see a fat model
uh you know advertising clothes I'm more
inclined not to buy it I actually click
off don't fat people deserve to know
what like if they're considering buying
I don't know a top address a lingerie
set a pair of shorts whatever don't they
deserve to know what they may look like
I'm sure it's all well and good it's
great it's great for them but it's
unhealthy for them it's also nice to see
what they might look like yeah
to look good in their wedding dress
is there plus size wedding dress now I
don't know
um I would say I want to add something
to the conversation in terms of why
there are more plus size models plus
size campaigns and clothing I think it's
if you look at it from the business
angle
corporations are only going to go where
the money is right exactly so if they
can see the trends and see that people
are getting fatter so obviously they're
going to be more fat people to sell to
so that also incentivizes them to create
and to support and to fund this fat uh
or that positivity they don't care about
it then it creates even more fat people
that's the point so that's why it's
actually dangerous it's not because you
guys are looking at it from a personal
angle of or it makes me feel better but
on the larger society for money they are
nefarious acts being done behind the
scenes to make sure that these things
continue
for a company to get a plus size model
or a company to encourage you to lose
weight it's not that it's hold on we're
talking about Corporate social
responsibility now and it's not like
it's not a company's responsibility per
se to encourage fat people to lose
weight
why is it a company by selling their
products why is it a company's
responsibility to tell you not to lit up
okay responsibility to tell you should
accept right firstly why did I do that
okay can I don't think they should like
I I don't think so you've got let's say
Lloyd's bank right pride month comes
around and all these companies who
actually have nothing to do with
sexuality Lloyd's bank is just an
example that I have they throw up a
different logo with the pride flag
Incorporated that is um like a lot of
people would call it virtual signatures
bigot now because just for more
questions you shouldn't do that no I
didn't say that they shouldn't do that
I'm saying no no no no no listen I want
you to listen very carefully because I
don't think what I'm saying is actually
that complex so a company that has
nothing to do with like let's say health
and fitness
um let's say I don't know like a Oral B
right they make toothbrushes should they
is it their responsibility to encourage
people to lose weight and eat healthy no
they should just sell toothbrushes and
toothpastes right then so why are we
having this conversation because you
just answered your own question what was
my question
if you don't remember it why should I
answer no so it was it was is it if
they're gonna do it and and hire fat
models to advertise their clothing and
and it's going to be on magazines
everywhere and it's going to be pushed
in the media that it's okay to be fat
then is it better to do that or is it
better for them to encourage people to
lose weight
they're already doing one yeah yeah
should they encourage the other actual
healthier about the companies that
you're talking about are not only
companies who actually have business
marketing to fat people like clothing
companies we're talking like they might
be advertising train tickets and they'll
have a plus size couple and people in
one school have thought would say that's
terrible you're encouraging people to be
fat and buy train tickets it's not the
train tickets company to encourage
people to lose weight we've all just
said the onus is on the individual if
you want to talk about corporate
Corporate social responsibility we have
to look at the companies who actually
profit from people being fat what about
that what about what about marketing to
kids yeah because they don't get any a
good good message so I would say hey
it's okay to be fair I would say that
the weight loss industry are the people
who profit most from people being fat
because they like Slimming World for
example is designed so that you keep
going back into it and back into it and
back into it that's why they give you
these Point systems and they do these
things that keep you trapped because
they want you to remain losing weight
forever they don't actually want you to
get fitted I'd rather assist the weight
loss industry is worse I'd rather a
society that sells weight loss pills
than a society that tells you hey it's
okay get fat
is a world full of green
green fresh tea
because his point is at least you're
going towards the ideal and instead of
saying you're okay as is not saying that
the pills are good but he's saying he
would rather live in a world where we
are at least trying to be thin fat
people go back to being fat you
acknowledge that you know the fact it's
true yeah the fashion industry doesn't
actually care about that plus size
because they don't when you order plus
size clothes it's poorer quality and the
cuts are just basic so the brands are
just doing what they're doing and the
biggest thing for me is why are they
still trying to give up keep big people
like transfers they make more money
no they don't make money because they're
just selling they're actually promoting
plus size they're just making things
that's actually popular now they make
more money no they're just making a
quick Buck because they don't actually
care there's no money it's not effort
efforts
right now the whole point isn't should
they push it it's that they do and right
now they do I don't think they do for
men I don't think you're right it's
mostly to Pander to women yeah I agree
body positivity is not a male movement
it's absolutely a female movement I I
agree yes plus size male models they're
like going online shopping sites there's
plus size male models but 100 is
targeted to more towards women because
men idolize people in good shape fitness
trainers uh people with good physiques
online because they want to go the
opposite route and get a good body to
attract a high quality woman well isn't
it because the market spends it's with
women women are like the consumers
you're right right so it's not it's not
necessarily that men it's like nothing
to do with men and being attractive it's
just that like women spend more money on
looking good no facts yeah I would say
yeah for in terms of fashion 100 that's
why there's more female plus size models
but men go in the opposite direction and
want to shred as much as they can or get
in the best shape possible who's buying
more protein supplements who's buying
more weight I'd probably not weight loss
supplements but just who's looking to
get big in the gym men
and not the not the big like fat big but
good physique we're not we're not stupid
we know what you mean like we yeah like
I'm pretty sure we're all in this
conversation and we we understand the
terminology around it I think there's
also something to be said around
treating bigger people who clearly like
are not pts and are not in the gym as
much as you guys are healthier fitter
people as if they were born yesterday a
lot of us like we know the facts it's
just that certain people are not doing
anything about it actively or some
people are on that journey and still
look big but there's a certain amount of
arrogance I think around people who are
fit and the way that they perceive
people who are unfit and how that
manifests as treatment I think which is
why like I've actually heard of that
woman who like she was really big and
she wants to buy it she thinks that
plane seats should be like three seats
wide because oh my God we spoke about
Alaska right because she can't like fit
in a single plane seat like that there's
a certain amount of ignorance from fit
people towards unfit people and I think
that's why what do you mean ignorance
arrogance and ignorance like just that
clarification it's like we know what you
mean by getting big in the gym it's like
there's context that I think I don't
think I don't think he was being
arrogant
almost I I think I think it's the other
way around I think the fat who are
asking for extreme on the plane are
claiming to be victims they're they're
the ones got walking around with
arrogance and saying hey I deserve
better treatment yeah whereas the fit
don't look it down on you they just look
at you maybe that you have a lack of
discipline or maybe maybe uh you could
make healthier choices I would encourage
all my fat mates to lose weight and get
in better shape that doesn't mean I look
down upon them do you think those are
back and forth between the fit and the
unfit and it's sort of like the anti
gets up to where you've got people
asking for like three literal plane
seats so that they can sit comfortably
on a plane and then you've got fit
people who are antagonizing fat people
for the way they look do you not think
there's a back and forth between those
two halves of what do you call
antagonize
I think like we're talking about
victimhood a lot of people who are big
and feel particularly sensitive about
being big they would see particular
comments as antagonizing whereas you
guys might see it as like a healthy bit
of bullying and it gets you to where you
want to be but people like being fat is
a very sensitive issue because it stems
from an emotional deficit and that's
something I think a lot of people would
accept as being true so if it stems from
an emotional deficit you know that it's
a sensitive side I think I think I think
fit people are trying to help
I think most fit people I mean I've even
offered I said any day you guys want to
work out 11AM 11 A.M coming I swear to
God I'll do it even even even one of my
my Purdue one of my my other producer
struggles with his weight I make him go
up the stairs with me like like I think
most fit people that I don't make if he
does it out of his Free Will don't don't
clip that but but no but like most fit
people will help you like most fit
people are encouraging but like I just
think we get to a point where fat people
don't want to talk about what's reality
yeah and the reality is it is an early
grave the reality is you shouldn't be
content at it as is the reality is a lot
of people will have problems because of
the choices that you make and that's
denied that though but but I I would say
maybe did
I'm not saying they're denying it I'm
saying the movement in general I'm not
talking about you guys personally says
to be content as is and focuses on
Mental Health I don't think we should
focus on Mental Health I think we should
focus on physical health first I just
think that both things can exist at once
and that's my standpoint like I I think
that you can want to be better and you
can improve yourself and you can also
not hold yourself back from things that
you want to do and with the plain seat
thing that's that's a really complicated
one because I can empathize with the
pain that they must feel how
embarrassing that must be and I can
understand the jerk reaction to be like
oh this needs to just be bigger I
understand that but like when I can go
down a slide my thought was not this
slide should be bigger right it was I
should be smaller like this is not
normal that I can't go down this slide
but I've also sat on a plane before
where I've had a bigger person next to
me and they've apologized for their
weight and I felt really sad that they
felt like they had to do that don't
don't you think like all of these
adjustments are enabling it like making
bigger clothes making bigger seats
making like putting models in the media
like is it in a way it's enabling it the
same way it's the same the same way
handing alcohol and making it easy easy
to drink is enabling an alcoholic
people used to train to fit in a wedding
dress a couple years ago now people used
to go to The Outpost country and be like
listen I want to get in this wedding
dress I want to be a certain weight
everyone still does that no I think
there are plus size uh no no no no no
come on 60 60 of us are overweight like
they do die when people get married they
I don't know anyone who's got married
and not tried to lose weight for their
wedding day yeah Phil's question was is
it enabling people to get fed up to a
degree no I don't I don't think that
anybody like I have a lot of skinny
friends most of my friends are skinny
and I don't think any of my skinny
friends have ever looked at me and been
like do you know what I'd like to get
fatter they've never it's just never
happened it's enabling you it's enabling
you they're not saying I want to get
fatter they're saying because you're
seeing it every oh and it's okay we can
do this that it's enabling them to get
further I don't know even if it's
subconsciously I can still eat it and
honestly like because I mean my big
thing is I have a sugar addiction I kind
of like it when people like when I'm
eating something bad and someone says
something to me about it like because
I'm like yeah I probably look at it like
I think it's helpful makes you feel
guilty yeah yeah and and I think those
things are part of normal conversations
though I don't think there's anything
necessarily wrong with that specifically
like my boyfriend is skinny and I'll say
that to him because he has a major Sweet
Tooth and he eats a lot of crap like and
I'll be like that is your second piece
of cake today you know like and he's not
fat like I think that's a normal
question but I think we're both mentally
stable people you can't say that to
everyone skinny people can have a high
visceral fat yeah
that's a huge thing that is missed out
in the body positivity movement and I
think it gets to a point where we have
to stop it's much deeper don't worry how
they want to be helped and help them how
they need to be helped it's like we
talked about it earlier right when
people have a really serious drug
addiction there comes a point where your
loved ones you have like a bit of an
intervention right and your people they
sit you down they say you need help
you're going to die your kids need you
around so off you go you're going to
rehab for six to 12 months and you're
not coming back until you sort yourself
out so at what point do we stop helping
people how they want to be helped and
help them how they need to be helped how
do fat people need to be helped
well it depends on the person well you
said no no they want to be that's how so
depending on the person is how they
would want to be helped no it depends
people in general need to be helped do
the government need to come in and say
okay no more McDonald's
a plus size model how could people
encourage what is the best way to
encourage people to lose weight for me I
found what I did encourage a lot of
people a lot of people were like oh yeah
I should lose weight too from the video
I made there was a really positive video
about wanting to help myself like I got
a lot of positive response from that I
got a little negative response from
people being like it makes me really sad
that you call yourself fat because I'm
bigger than you because I made a few
jokes I like picked fun at myself and I
called myself fat in the video and that
made some people feel bad well then you
should tell them they're fat too
they should work out I don't know it's
not how I think though I just don't
think like that and I don't think I just
ask you that I don't think accommodating
is necessarily enabling in the same way
if you want to compare it to drug
addiction I would say that there are
healthy ways to use drugs and like I
think it's in the Netherlands they have
places you can go where you can shoot up
with clean needles and things like that
and I think that harm reduction is much
better than just saying no it's like
celibacy it just doesn't work no I mean
as like I I had I had a cousin that died
from like drug addiction and I'm sorry
to hear that I mean it's okay it was a
while ago but I just don't think that
enabling's like I wouldn't look at
someone that gave him drugs in a healthy
way and say oh thank you for that I I
think I think it was it would actually
be a negative thing I think there's a
difference between enabling and
accommodating and and one is realistic
yeah is it a means to an end
accommodating and like
um safe usage that's a means to an end
right the end is that you'd hope that
the person stops using drugs
accommodating fatness the end is that
you hope that the person yeah so in the
same vein how is a person going to stop
using drugs if they're being given it
safely and how is a fat person going to
stop getting fat or maintain his weight
if he doesn't stop or he or she doesn't
stop eating so
interesting that I am across recently
was as a plus size model I was thinking
like I want to make my own brand I want
to invest a lot of money into something
and start producing something and I
thought about making plus size lingerie
I thought that making plus size clothes
I could just some financial advisors I
spoke to a few people and everybody told
me do not do it because there's no money
in staying fat like that is what I was
told by professionals they were like the
money isn't losing weights but why
because he asked you a question like
what's the best way to help fat people
isn't it diet and exercise
oh go ahead
the best way to lose weight is
to first start telling yourself that
it's one step at a time one step at a
time
um have a plan give yourself okay
imagine I do 10 sit ups today tomorrow
I'm gonna go for 15. if it's too hot I'm
gonna do 15 on the third day then I'm
gonna push myself to do 20 and along
with that he's even trying new foods and
just eating fresh things the diet and
extreme it's diet and exercise but a lot
of people that don't lose weight is
because of mobility issues so it's again
if I can't do this with my knee what can
I do how can I move my eyes not everyone
has a mobility issue like for the last
three years like governments have put
out ad campaigns you should you should
take this it's safe or you know smoking
ads are put up on television would you
guys be opposed to a government ad
saying if you continue eating this way
you're gonna die that's why they have
this cancer
losing weight
is 20 Fitness and it's 80 nutrition so
when you're talking about Mobility
um it has nothing to do with setups I
don't have to do with running or in the
gym is is 80 diet anyway so
if you want to lose weight then nobody
80 percenters nobody 20 percenters and
you personalize your program to that
also when people if you want to do
something I need to I need to comment
because there are a couple of things
that I want to push back on from
something that Pierre said it goes back
to every like a lot of these things tie
back to each other you said both things
can exist at the same time that that
that in my opinion is a very wrong
ideology because if you say you can
wants to lose weight and at the same
time enjoy your body the way it is in
its current state I I think that is you
actually stopping yourself from actually
losing weight because both things can't
actually exist at the same time it goes
back to the same thing we talk about on
this podcast where women want everything
you can't have everything in life so if
you really want to lose weight you need
to
um
how will I put it you need to basically
starve yourself of certain things
those things and trying to lose weight
because you wouldn't lose weight so for
instance like you said the beginning
should be earned when you stop yourself
from wearing a bikini till you earn it
you would actually get that goal you're
saying this but if you yeah but if
you're if you're
able to wear the bikini on a Sunday and
say you're going to go to the gym on
Monday you're not going to work as hard
in the gym I think that you're confusing
like um a step ethics and health there
because for me those things aren't
particularly linked I want to lose
weight because I want to be healthy but
I don't dislike the way that I like I'm
not confusing it I'm not confusing you
know why because a lot of times we try
to be
um deeper than we actually should be a
lot of these things are actually very
social trying to make it more complex
before you can talk about all these
things about the mind or your eyes are
the first thing that you used to see so
your your brain is going to work on what
it sees so no matter what you try to
tell yourself in your head
your eyes to see what you look like and
that's the reason why I wanted to ask
the question to the personal trainers
because it's very funny people asked
what is the best way to lose weight and
with all due respect I don't think
um you're in the right position to
answer that question um
partially was correct I know but the
reason why I'm saying that is because
this is the thing you
um it's like
that question should have been answered
by the personal trainers in my opinion
because one they have worked with people
that help people lose weight so they
know if even if
if you haven't done it you saying it is
kind of like okay
it kind of counteracts your argument
there are personal trainers who actually
don't understand
injuries they don't literally they don't
understand it because they keep on
working with fit people and that's why
they just ain't nobody no there's a lot
of there's a lot of locally like yeah
like people because there's something
you said no this thing that makes me
know that you don't really understand
this because you said something like
um when you go to the gym it's scary you
see these people working out the reality
is because I worked in a gym the reality
is some the fittest people are actually
the most important okay okay because
they've had to do the hard work they
know
that's why we do just last week I think
what you do what you've done essentially
is you've you put a mental block on
yourself so you see things that are
actually not there you go into the gym
you see people looking at you and you
think oh my God they're judging me the
reality is most people don't even care
about other applications okay so I
joined the gym a week and a half ago in
Essex now it's my induction and some
things obviously I know how to use
because I use it but because I want to
improve myself
I was like so are you going to show me
around like he's like yeah that's that
that's that and I'm like suddenly going
to show me how to use it because I at
least want to use it and then he goes
well you're not going to use it are you
I'm like why am I joining then I'm like
you need you shouldn't be working my
literally talking yeah that's what my
experience yeah that's just a bad
experience I know but no but it happens
a lot and it's not large because that's
what I mean by encouragement that when
people aren't used to working hey hey 11
A.M tomorrow
this I was just going to say this
you offered this same thing the last
time he was here and between then and
now we haven't seen you here can I say
why can I can I tell you why why my
dad's got cancer and he's been in
hospital and this week I actually gave
him his sponge bath and
when you're gonna lose a father
and when you're seeing them deteriorate
you ain't like
it's like I've just been going it's like
I don't have any emotions so sorry to
hear about I've just been keeping busy
and a part of keeping busy is I know I
need to drink water and and actually
care for myself which is keeping active
and getting good sleep and literally
eating healthy and that's the way I'm
living now and when I go to work stuff
that you see on Instagram Tick Tock
events and stuff like that I only go
there get the picture done take a few
say hello to a few people and leave and
then I wake up I've been hospitaled and
I've got errands to do
I cook and clean at home I do I do the
caring when my when my nephews are here
I'm an uncle I actually read books to
them I teach them how to cook because I
want them to have real skills so when
they go out and I take them out to like
we learn about things nature all these
things so you don't have any personal
time for yourself
I don't actually know and and that's the
thing when when P when someone's losing
their life
or they will hopefully they don't you
just have to be positive and there needs
to be that okay and I'm someone who
cares about my dad and I have and I have
a lot of like empathy for that but it's
like you're sitting on a couch for three
hours here so it kind of just shows
where your priorities are so can I say
something you've been here like TW and
you know keep coming you know you're
very good conscience social media as
well nothing nothing like personal but
it kind of shows like where your
priorities are because you have time
with that sounding rude as much as I
love this podcast when Romeo asked me I
was that Romeo
because I actually really wanted to
watch yeah and don't you know because
why because it helps me keep active I'm
gonna dance I'm gonna be like grooving I
swear it's I have a good time podcasts
ain't really me but coming on your
podcast because I enjoy you yeah oh I'm
actually I'm not
my point is my point isn't about the
podcasting it's just I think we all make
choices
right sorry I just need to I want to
share personal experience so this might
help you
um when I started working here I went
through certain personal things in my
life which I'm not going to dispute and
disclose but I think Pearl knows a few
of them but the point I'm trying to make
is for the longest time even after I
started getting my life back on track I
wasn't working out I'm someone you might
look at me I think I'm fit but I'm only
just starting to get my fitness back but
the reality is the reason why I wasn't
working out was because of all this life
stress and all of that and even when I
kind of started getting my life on track
I still wasn't working out but reality
is because that was happening because I
wasn't prioritizing it once I started I
got punched in the ribs when we were
sparring the other day and I kind of
woke up and I was like you know what I'm
gonna make time for the gym
and I have been able to create the time
so the reality is no matter what you're
going through in life you can always
create time for the things that most
important do you know what it is because
I was I was when I pressed most of my
life I've been in bed most of my life
okay so being active is actually a thing
can I can I just add to that
I just want to ask one question what's
the what's the one thing that you spend
most money on
when you don't have time
travel and food travel and food would
you say that if you want to lose weight
and get better why not spend that money
on a nutritionist
so whereas is not physical is something
a little bit more personalized program
where this person can help you even if
you don't have time which is what Bill's
saying priorities listening to you guys
I know why I am also plus size is
because literally I am busy and I've
always been busy which is fine and and
I can't fully share how it is for me
because I'm once I do my goals that I
need to do my career that's why I could
share my story about
I've suffered and I suffer and I don't
take mental health as an excuse I hear
what mental health experts have got to
say but to me I'm like no if I hear what
mental health experts have to say
although I go through it I'm like no
because if I hear that that's it I'm
falling into and the Brain I learned the
power
the power of the brain you can really
push yourself there's there are things
like and um 11AM tomorrow let's push
yourself come on
to get on a coach 11 A.M the next time I
just remember there is always a way and
do not okay yes yes you're right there's
no way um I'm stressing on suffering
I don't want to play Devil's Advocate
but like you know I think everyone
suffers everyone has a point of suffer
of course would you guys say that
overweight people tend to have more
excuses
I think just in this like conversation
we could say yes
sometimes I'm not gonna lie when when
you're not feeling it it's like when
you're big you're always constantly
feeling heavy and even like exercising
is heavy and then the muscle pain
I could say the say I have a sugar
addiction right and there's this um
there's a like sort of a nutrition guy
that like texts me and he's like how's
your sugar and I'm like bad bad and it's
because of my own choices it's because I
lack discipline that's it it's because I
lack discipline and I keep making that
choice pure sugar coffee there is that
but how about I tell you when you when
like and now that I've got it on like
I'm better but in the past when I've
exercised that exercise session will put
me into bed for a week I wouldn't be
eating then we gotta figure out so
that's why I've been walking that's why
I say my best ways but so so we got to
figure out maybe it's diet maybe it's
just diet like I know what it is it's me
it's me actually what what do you guys
think is more effective someone being
strict in the gym or strict with their
diet diet for sure been saying it you
don't even need to go gym baby stones
but even when you were saying like
you're one of your number one
like I I notice when my food bill is
high that's when I gain weight because
I've been eating out actually healthy
people don't drive expensive gas
what Ricardo and Driver oh gas one
healthy food is expensive you know fuel
to be able to move no it's nice Okay no
Okay look at okay look at the average
juice you want to buy a good an a
natural pressed juice and you want to
buy that much
water yes okay yeah how do you drink
water I do and I love I love juice and
sugar dry like that's like my My
Kryptonite so I get it but at the end of
the day it's just a choice like we could
drink water it is a choice and
addictions people do have addictions
it's different for different people how
I've got willpower some people may not
and it's just the way it is I think
there's a lot more willpower for a lot
of people they think that the willpower
is in going to the gym but it is
actually in what you eat because I I
think one of the super chats said this
and this was the point I was going to
make you you have to discipline the one
thing you rely on right we're talking
about drug addiction we're talking about
smoking people don't need to smoke to
live but you do need to eat to live
thing is you cannot out exercise a poor
diet right because there's only so many
hours in the day and your body has a
physical limit you could eat 12
cheeseburgers and then like get on the
treadmill for as long as you can and you
know you can't really you can't out
exercise the 12 cheeseburgers that you
ate which is why it probably does need
to start with diet and we were talking
about companies and corporate social
responsibility earlier look at how much
uh like the cheapest burger from
McDonald's is like less than a pound or
something or at least it was
um but then if you go and buy like a lot
of people would compare and I've seen
this all over Instagram like McDonald's
is really cheap compared to fruit or
vegetables or a gym membership and
that's what a lot of people
who like really support the body
positivity movement would come back with
like it's about cost and and convenience
and that's why going back to foreign
honestly my dad he he's always been like
thinner like in shape pretty much like
never really struggled with it he lives
on fast food but he just doesn't need a
lot some people are just blessed no he's
not blessed he just runs and do you
think
also eats a lot of like chicken from
those places so do you think being fat
is a result of your environment too
because my dad partial my dad runs a gym
and that's how I got into the gym
do you guys feel like maybe it's because
of the environment of course actually
that's that's my my next one question I
had is is is
yes obesity for children child abuse
absolutely
right hold on Obesity for children yes
if a child's obese is because the adult
is feeding them yeah and where yes if
they're not aware no because some
because some grandparents are like my
child has to eat they have to have this
they have to have that I noticed so you
guys all said yes immediately do you
feel like you're in the position you're
in because you were fed bad food as a
child absolutely not because and I I
said this last time I hate to sound
repetitive for the people who love the
show but like your circumstances may not
be your fault but it's your
responsibility to change it
I just correct right but I'm saying like
when you were younger did that were you
always big or did you get big when you
were older
um I was smaller when I was younger and
then it just like every year like I've
just gotten bigger okay I was just
wondering if the food you ate at home
affected that or no I think to a degree
it did but I think a lot of it is just
adult okay like uh I really think fried
chicken and chicken and chip shops in
East London ruined to me
no I'm just being honest because growing
up in my household there was fish there
was vegetables there was everything and
it was home cooked and my mom was always
health conscious as well so it is what's
it's again it just goes to show if you
grew up in a community where there are
things like that and they're promoted
and they're cheap you will eat it and
you will get big and that's what exactly
will happen
um what do you guys think child abuse
100 yeah for sure I'd say it like it's a
parent's responsibility to care for
their kids and if you're getting to a
point where they're extremely unhealthy
or obese then it is child abuse oh my
God yes guys I mean I have a niece back
home and every time I'm on a video call
with my parents and they're feeding that
I'm like don't give her too much of
macaroni don't give up too much of this
on that like make sure she's eaten small
portions make sure she's eternality so
your your family's obese
what is this like conversations like
with you no no no no I mean I'm saying
my niece yeah when I see them feeding
her no you just every time you've been
in the show a couple times you always
mention you're overweight like family
so I'm just wondering like what do you
what are your conversations like like do
you tell them my family yeah all the
time okay yeah even my cousin that died
she saw the last um podcast and she even
came to me and she was like oh my God
everything you guys was talking about
was right I was like great so you should
be giving yourself that that type of
advice
but again it wasn't up to me yeah it was
up to her to take the advice on herself
you know what I mean one of the
um things that I would say on terms of
like children like I was a skinny kid
like I grew up skinny uh but one thing
that I will never do that my parents did
with me that I think a lot of parents do
of people who get overweight as adults
is um food was like a reward if I did
well at school I got to go for a nice
dinner
um I got a treat if I did good at
something and so when I was in
university in like drama school and I
got into this binge Purge restrict
routine
um that was partly where like the
dopamine Rush came from eating junk food
was because when I grew up because I ate
so healthy as a kid junk food was a
reward and when I have kids like I'd
like to have a much healthier and if
they do well in an exam like I would
never take them for a meal to celebrate
that I'd do something else that was part
of my issue okay
what do you think I feel like it's child
abuse only because the child has no
control over what they can or cannot eat
at the end of the day your parent will
cook for you and then they'll be like
there's the food on the table go and eat
so where you were saying that you were
rewarded like when you were being like
good or whatever my dad he's an athlete
so if when the moment I started putting
away he would decide nope he used to
make me do four laps around a track
I used to see him four laps sausage and
the slower I got he'll be
I'll be reprimanded again you'll be like
oh well like it wouldn't be good for me
in any shape or form
so for me I feel like I've taken a lot
of sacrifices I haven't always been the
size I used to be once a lot bigger and
then because of my diagnosis I said to
myself listen I have to make the
sacrifice so I became vegan and informed
that that's where I decided to lose more
weight as well I need to be as light as
possible so that I can manage my
condition as well as other people so if
I have a relapse tomorrow and I'm like
well 200 kilograms or 120 kilograms or
whatever I'm gonna be a lot harder to
manage than If I Was 80 kilograms do you
get on Tennessee so for me personally
you have to kind of think of the
longevity of your life otherwise
you know
there's no value in them
I have a question for the bodybuilders
bodybuilders yeah um if someone wanted
to lose weight wait which Step do you
because I hear there's a lot that you
need to attack you from both sides do
everything but I actually don't think
that's correct I think you have to start
somewhere right so somewhere to start
would you advise them to change that
diet first or go to the gym first if
it's an obese person I'm saying ease
yourself into it that you don't have to
go nuts in the gym straight off the bat
I think you've got to go die at first
like like the guys that said 80 diet 20
exercise diet first easy way into it go
then then move your way into exercise
walking then resistance training slowly
you know other forms of equipment but
you have to work up towards it your
body's going to react pretty suddenly to
it but definitely die at first and the
reason to that is um the first thing
I'll do with our client is I'll put them
on the most gym sub skills right and
these skills give you um certain numbers
when your clients see these numbers now
you have to explain to them what
category they're in you know this is
healthy this is heading into the danger
zone or this is alarming
and
that is by diet
there's not much that the gym could do
with these numbers so now you have to
explain to this person okay
yes we're gonna start trading and this
is the particular type of training that
you will be doing but no because of what
because of the lifestyle that your your
doing right now it needs to change and
because of the diet you have right now
it needs to change because whatever
you're doing right now is a causing
these numbers to grow and to get into
the alarm in range so I'd say 100
um that
okay
I thought it was a personal trainer as
well
oh okay now about 100 no I feel like
it's more so director are you not a
trainer foreign
[Music]
no 100 I feel like Diet first and then
after that it would be like exercising
so because you need to create some sort
of sustainable lifestyle for yourself so
you need to ease yourself into it and be
able to like you know micromanage
yourself into you know what I'm trying
to say you know what's great about that
we actually disagree with all three of
them
I think you're wrong I mean I can prove
you wrong as well but you could prove
you want to try it you wanna you want us
to go
[Music]
you take one fat person I'll take
another fat person let's say you get the
best results
okay 11 A.M tomorrow but in terms of
like the discussion the reason why I say
I think that's that's well I wouldn't
say it's inquiry because there's no
right way to anything but the reason why
I don't think that's the most optimal
way is because
um
one
companies benefit from this whole
ideology behind dieting so if you look
at where the money goes usually you
should go in the opposite direction so
um
I always think of it like this if I have
to pay money for anything I'll rather do
the thing that's free
going to working out is free you can go
for a run on the road you can do all of
that and the reason why I think working
out is better first is because
I think it's more sustainable and it
gives you more of a feedback than
dieting dieting is very broad it's like
it's almost like when you say dieting
most people are confused they don't even
know what you're talking about nice I
have a question but the reason why I
think working out is actually more
important is because if you go to the
gym every day and you're able to stay
consistent with that your body will give
you feedback one two the harder it gets
it will get harder first before it gets
easier right yeah but that will motivate
the same the same goes for a diet though
the reason why I'm trying to make this
point is because these days when when uh
an era where people Hammer so much on
mental health and all this crap right
actually I agree that these are the
things that hindering people from
achieving these goals right the reality
is you cannot have a strong mind without
a strong body first right but both
require discipline having a good diet
and and exercising regularly but you
still have to build a strong body to get
to the strong mentors you gotta get
you've got to get yourself to a point to
build the strong body
start straight away you can build a
strong body even when you don't want to
so you can have people fast okay so say
you're exercising still yeah but you're
still eating like a pig
the more you keep exercising the more
the discipline comes because that's if
you're working hard at exercise and
you're seeing that you're still putting
on this effort you can get into your
goals and your body is still giving you
that um feedback of you do this and it's
painful you would want to improve in
other areas to make that endeavor easier
yeah
you could burn a thousand calories and
eat 4 000 calories it just I think you
got to start with your diet first yeah
I'm sorry go ahead I was gonna say how
disagree and agrees because if you start
having a consistency and discipline yes
you're gonna get stronger
um you're gonna get stronger mindsets
you're gonna get fitter body but then
when you continue eating poor diet then
they're definitely not gonna change but
what it is what I'm saying when you work
out what it will do
I think um the part that I agree on is
because of that discipline and
consistency it is going to encourage you
to eat healthier because you know start
feeling better you know start feeling
better it will encourage you to eat more
healthy and that's the part I agree on
you on
um but still they I mean diet wins
they're working out even when I started
working out again I I was saying for the
longest I'm going to stop physically
drinking because I didn't actually stop
until I started going to the gym yeah so
because they didn't go in the stairs
actually the start of everything yeah
yeah you see that you see the elevator
we do the stairs
for me yeah but I think no you're a
little bit more conscious on your diet
though right yeah yeah that's in the
process of I've really tried to lose
weight I find it much easier to eat
better on days I've worked out that
morning because I have this whole thing
in my head of like I don't wanna do it I
don't want to do it I don't want to do
it you know whereas if I haven't worked
out that day I'm like well yeah you know
what I mean it is easier but the diet is
the more effective thing like I used to
never ever do this but when I was uh
skinnier I used to do water fasts
um particularly for roles or for
auditions when I was an actor I would
water fast for like five days and I
would lose like two pounds a day it
could not be me yeah no I would say that
that's like that takes a lot of
discipline it's very very hard but like
I was like not okay when I did this do
you guys think that weight loss programs
are toxic
toxic work if they if they include
um taking non-natural things yeah but if
it's natural and if it's just using your
own way and equipment that is no harm to
you then no it's not toxic only gets
toxic when you add the drugs I think
it's the execution of the weight loss
program that makes it not necessarily
toxic but unhelpful
um and it doesn't serve the individuals
what about the company what about the
biggest loser
people
get pair them up with personal trainers
prominent personal trainers and they
would see who would lose the most weight
did they gain it back very entertaining
show a lot a lot it did I would love to
watch if that came back oh I might even
go anywhere but a lot of a lot of the
personal trainers we have one in
Australia we can make our own version we
should do it yeah yeah yeah but a
personal trainer back in Australia who
was on the show Michelle Bridges got
canceled because she would have a go at
magazines Media or pushing body
positivity and larger women on magazines
and I think the same thing happened with
a US personal trainer on The Biggest
Loser yeah it did that's her field she's
in Fitness
should she even be getting canceled for
saying this is unhealthy no
I'm kidding
sensitivity again right it's this um
it's the fact that we want to sort of
Molly cuddle people into we want to wrap
them in Cotton wall and protect their
feelings and if a personal trainer is on
you know a bit more of the brutal side
and their approach is a little bit more
boot camp-esque they are less palatable
less desirable to people who are
potentially not as serious as as serious
about their goals or people who just
don't take kindly to being shouted abuse
yeah so you see there's no watch you see
as whole
uh she said execution not in that there
is a lot in how you say it yeah yeah and
how weight loss programs like approach
things I like it when my trainer is a
little mean to me just a little bit
I've realized in your own little ways
you know it's kind of like the teacher
you like the one that's a bit strict you
know yeah
no no I just think you know otherwise
I'll otherwise I'll I'll cancel the
personal training you know if they don't
yell at me I'll I'll be your outlines if
you're not hard on them they will
concert yeah especially if they if you
cancel and they're like oh it's okay no
it's not okay stop letting me do that
even if you charge me yeah I agree I'm
tired
generally in love are you more dominant
or like would you say
um would you say you're more dominant or
you're more on the opposite of dominance
what's submissive you know it depends on
the environment I played sports for a
while so I would say in sports I was
more dominant as an athlete yeah you
would rather a coach that is strict and
more you want to play for the coach yeah
so when you bring up our workout
routines toxic
at the end of the day it's up to the
individual if you don't like the way
they're executing it you can leave go to
the next personal trainer absolutely but
you know you want someone that's going
to keep you accountable at the end of
the day yeah [__] sucks
it ends on the waitlist program because
as I said earlier
they're almost designed to
you to leave and then gain weight and
come back and a lot of things are like
that well what's a non-toxic weight loss
program to you nutritionist personal
trainer
because you've got to keep that in the
long term but the is like um fast lost
like accountability weight loss things
they're all supposed to help each other
like Slimming World and Weight Watchers
I think that they make a lot of money of
the same people
my mom lost like 50 pounds on weight
loss Watchers is that a bad one do you
know what toxic toxic health is muscle
and Health Muscle meals and health foods
toxic then it's the same as Weight
Watchers we have a thing in Australia
called The Man shake for men that are
overweight the dad Bots they instead of
having a meal they replace it with a
shake the design people have lost people
have lost hundreds of kilos on the
Mansion is that bad could
to everything like 80 of people gain the
weight back so no like I I don't think
there's any weight loss program that's
not successful that's why which my next
question is why do you think that is
because it shouldn't be
a short term eight-week weight loss
program it should just be a lifestyle
change that's what it is so that was my
question for the trainers why do 80 of
people gain the weight back
yeah it'd be probably dieting fat
dieting intermittent fasting thing and
this is going to solve the problem it's
really just about consistency and doing
whatever else I think it is the shakes
your body starts out your body starts
consistently having as soon as you
change adaptation like as soon as you
you break that it could it changes but
that's why diets don't work that's my
point now what John said it is literally
you need to change your life the mindset
of what about you listen to me wanting
to actually be aware of what you're
eating drinking diets don't work and
I'll tell you why because it's almost
like saying the human we are not
designed to eat like you can't say
someone should eat the same thing for
because if you lose your weight on diets
then you're gonna have to maintain it
with that diet and you can't stay on
that same diet for the rest of your life
so the idea is if you lose weight on
this diet eventually you're going to go
back to eating whatever you like eating
you know the reality is if you build
your body to the point where because I
don't I don't eat healthy I hear we're
trying I don't eat all of that the
reason why I'm able to stay and keep my
body fit is because I've played Sports
all my life I've been in the gym almost
all my life and even for like the past
three four years that I I didn't step in
the gym for a single hour all the work I
had done prior to that is what is
sustaining me so feta people have a high
appetite yes metabolism is it the reason
why people stay obese is because their
metabolism slows down and stops and the
only way to relax
metabolism is to move exactly you need
to move your body you can't do whatever
diet you like it is never going to work
yeah without consistency though a
hundred it has to be consistent at the
same time so yeah you can say diets
don't work or and whatever metabolism is
the reason why people stay fat but at
the end of the day it's personal
accountability yeah keeping yourself in
a calorie deficit for a long period of
time it's very simple you know what I
was thinking about but when you said the
average like job are you sacrificing
your health you kind of are because
you're sitting for eight hours a day
there's ways to stay healthy you can no
there are but I'd say like the average
person in a way in Corporate America you
do like they don't really I worked in
Corporate America okay they didn't look
healthy a lot of them yeah Wall Street
do a lot of cocaine as well well you
know that's a different problem
we'd fit people they do a lot of coke
that's one thing for sure you know I've
never seen a person do this
that everyone always has the sniffles I
could never come down
I could never come there like the
corporate nine to five has a standard
tree lifestyle I think it's called where
you're just behind the desk
every job has its uh yeah and it's just
like you know that's work I think with
uh weight loss programs like Weight
Watchers and Slimming World they
actually ultimately end up disempowering
people because I can't remember which
one it is and I don't know if they still
do it but they attribute what they call
sins to like good foods and bad foods
and they don't actually talk about
calories so the person who's on the
weight loss program becomes attached to
this concept of sins but that's really
unhelpful because you might say an
orange has two sins but chocolate bar
has one and it doesn't actually help you
evaluate the nutritional profile of
either one and so where these programs
become I don't know if I'd say toxic but
unhelpful is where you're not actually
giving people the numbers and you're not
giving them the data if you have the
knowledge then you can make the choices
it's knowledge and choices we need to
educate people
well I think the question was uh
um sort of like was it workout programs
and stuff like are they helpful or toxic
and I think that some of them can be
unhelpful if it's something like why do
we why do we skip nutrition as they go
to weight loss programs
I can't answer that question because I
haven't done that yeah it's all a
business money money money they bring
all the Honeys it's all the business
guys
why do we escape the right people to go
to the people that [__] and everyone
I wonder if it's yeah it's it's the BS
right you want things to be you know pun
intended but you want it easy yeah sugar
coated right the nutritionist is like a
long-term solution it's also cheap to go
to Weight Watchers in Slimming World
it's not that cheap I think the personal
nutritionist in comparison to going to
these weekly groups the nutrition the
nutritionists are a bit more
personalized
it is more expensive but I think it's a
little bit I know like we're talking
about smoking and drug addiction and if
being obesity it's like a food addiction
is there AA for fat people
I know I she did there's something it's
not that popular it's not that kind of
they go around the room I've been fat
for this yeah it's like an online
community I just know my aunt actually
said something to me she lost like a ton
of weight through it it yeah wow wow I
don't at least it's fat people giving
each other accountable yeah yeah it's um
ah gosh I wish I could remember the name
there there's something like that though
I don't know if they're in person
meetings though I think it's like online
maybe Zoom yeah I think people get
scared if they saw a group of 12 fat
people like huddled together it'd be
like a bit of a fat cult I think
oh my God I mean I think that's like the
average American woman was a fat I just
can't well maybe that would just be that
would just be a normal day I was there
in South Beach last week and like come
from Australia to in going into Florida
seeing the amount of people that are
overweight is crazy like it is a
epidemic over there the amount of these
people there are and it's just like just
the average person looks overweight just
the average person oh my gosh but when I
see a group of big people together he
does genuinely scare me because I know
how much I weigh I've broken a lot of
beards plastic I'm scared of plastic
seeds so I'm scared of like little
things like that and so when I see a
group of big people although I don't
discriminate because I know how much
I'll be in the things that are broken
when they come together is scary also
I'll have another fear big women in
heels are scared I'm scared for them
just in case it snaps and it's not even
that and I actually saw someone in it it
happened to me on the bus and I thought
the way of the shoulder on my feet and
I'm never gonna forget it and now when I
see big present I'm always that kind of
like oh I I wanna I wanna try and catch
you just in case you fall can I just be
real
character or like a very
real life experiences here this is not a
joke oh my God I am a real person would
you be afraid if they came in in heels
no no like that you know like imagine
wearing like a party or something and
the dogs next to me no but if I saw the
stick was just like a pencil no that is
scary for me and this is not a
discrimination this is like literally
health and safety for myself because I
felt someone shoulder on my foot alive
and I remember
oh my God you guys am I making you guys
laugh sorry I didn't know I didn't know
plus size seals were a thing
she just said she just said there if
they were a pencil scene you know what
I'm talking about well so uh a person
who is rational and actually cares about
their safety I don't say health and
safety but someone who cares about their
safety like you're not gonna catch me in
a stiletto because I'd have the same fit
that is gonna snap good snap yeah but
like you make the the right choices and
they are there are actually Hills for
bigger people that are designed to hold
your weight everything
I'm learning so much about the
plus-sized world
accommodations that have to be made
right
plus size heels are enabling
I do
okay okay just imagine if you guys
couldn't buy clothes anywhere I just
think you might lose weight quicker yeah
like if you couldn't if you think I'd
just be naked wouldn't I if I couldn't
buy clothes
if I couldn't buy clothes anywhere the
first thing I would be is naked okay
I think you'd make arrangements you'd
get some cloths and then you'd start
losing weight to buy clothes elsewhere
yeah you'd make arrangements
it's like I want someone to work out
with me so bad I'm always by myself
11 A.M tomorrow so I
can't come some days okay okay I've got
Doms right now I was at the gym
yesterday I haven't been in the gym for
ages well you say nice it bloody hurts
like it's supposed to be a reward isn't
it like when you've got um
yeah they say that but it bloody hurts
and I think I just pushed myself too
hard my we were talking about what the
Tipping Point is for someone who is Big
like at what point do you change your
life for me I just realized that I
wasn't as it was a Mobility thing I
wasn't as flexible as I used to be and I
was like wait I could do that before
with no issue and now like it I can
still do it but it's an effort so I went
to the gym
I threw my back out helping someone else
like being some sort of emergency spot
thinking that I could do something I
couldn't save the guy threw my back out
um but then I went to the gym yesterday
and worked out it was great it was
really fun
but I think I just like I let it go for
so long that I didn't lift weights and
then I thought I did something really
easy I was doing like 18 kilos on
various weight machines and it was fine
at first like when I was in the gym I
was like yeah this is the easiest light
work I mean you know hike up to 24 32
but today I'm in so much pain and that
is another
um like unintended outcome of just not
going to the gym for ages a lot of
people think yeah I'll just gain a bit
of weight but actually it gets harder
and it's there comes a point where it's
I won't say that you know you're too far
gone because people have been 600 pounds
and and gone the other way but it
definitely becomes harder and I think a
lot of people develop this mindset that
they are too far gone
and then they just never do anything
about it yeah I've seen loads of posts
recently about famous people having
heart attacks and like I look in the
comments because I'm like well this
person's 400 pounds I I feel like I know
why they they had a heart attack I look
in the comments and people like you're
no it's because they had this they had
that and you know it's like you never
you're never you're never too far gone
there's always a person that's done it
there's always a person that achieved it
and it can all start at 11 A.M tomorrow
let me let you in on a little secret as
well you see that pain you felt it does
it doesn't happen to only people that
are overweight I know yeah I'm very fit
and when I went to the gym the next day
I felt like I was going to die that is
not normal
even even when I'm at my fitness I still
feel that pain the difference is fit
people understand that that pain equals
growth yeah so other people would look
at it like ah okay now this is painful
I'm gonna stop no if you don't feel that
pain then you probably didn't even work
out yeah exactly all right so basically
Pearl you keep on talking about that
11AM
so um if you're watching earlier I would
like to propel you're really gorgeous
you know I'm telling you you need to
like wear like some fashionable clothes
and then she told me to send her a DM
with the clothes that I think she should
wear so I think people should vote but
what do they want to watch you getting
dressed in a new outfit and feeling on
flat and looking cool or do they want to
watch me and you exercise I think you
should ask your followers that because
put a poll in the chat if they pick the
workout will you come what if I have to
do it
come on
being dressed up in good fashion
actually celebrating yourself and
getting your features that because she
just wears clean clothes and I feel like
there's nothing wrong with it because
that's her it's not about me trying to
change her fashion it's just adding
little cuteness in a pop of color
because
she she comes across as this mean person
or whatever very opinionated but I see
right through her and she she needs to
something no I'm sure all the pills
followers want her to take fashion
advice Sugar Puff no I'm I'm telling you
you're gonna look hey hey let's let's
we'll do a poll we'll do all right you
do the poll they do the workout one are
you coming yes I'll do the workout well
I'll attempt it I won't I won't silence
if they choose the fashion one are you
gonna go and and I'm not bad because
you're buying them I'm just shopping
them for you that's fine that's fine all
right okay that's cool wow a hundred
percent says losing weight
see you at 11AM look at the end of the
day
um
actually trying to be healthy and if
Pearl wants to do it why not I'll do it
but you got the devote what do you want
to watch Pearl getting your makeover I
did oh Sugar Puff exercise
no I can't come tomorrow it has to be
organized another day I'm not trying to
get out of my genuine January
Saturdays no they have to have a long
government major or something else
all right all right well um this was a
fun panel guys
um we are gonna close out the show
we could stay here all night
uh but you know I do have to get up at
11AM
[Laughter]
which you know 70 oh 20 it's going up
your way but it's still something listen
we are gonna look put look fire she's
gonna be she's gonna look like a
material girl
I just don't know how to get you to pose
but I just don't think it's me what you
you're right but you know what the
leopard well I see you I see your
personalities it's just me seeing you
and the way I see you and what the
goodness that I've seen you that's how
I'm gonna address you basically wow so
yeah I love the energy that's that's the
aim not to change you to enhance just
what the things that you like oh it's
profound no you put some serious energy
today yeah uh well here's the part part
of the show where we do final thoughts
you can put your social media I really
appreciate everyone coming out I feel
like this was a very a nice panel
without heated you know
um you know so I'm starting here final
thoughts go around and then we'll second
row final thoughts oh
um I'm not a body positivity Warrior
just because I am a fat person it
doesn't mean I can be the spokesperson
for all fat people
um I absolutely believe in being healthy
I believe that there are ways and means
to do it that don't uh endanger the
health of the individual
but all in all I'm I'm for being healthy
and that's something that I'm
prioritizing myself
I am for body positivity
um I believe people should be happy in
their bodies
um I don't believe in unhealthy body
positivity where you eat junk and you're
gonna have a heart attack and you're
gonna die no I don't agree with that
um a message is Instagram tick truck is
Sugar Puff official
s-u-g-a-p-u-f-f official and today the
100 pound egg dropped on pop.com it's by
James abardi who's worked on Big Brother
I'm a celebrity get me out of here and I
think you all will really enjoy 100
pound egg another thing people cannot go
on can I finish what I need to say so
I'm working on my celebrity one-to-one
chats I am so sick and tired of
celebrities not actually promoting the
good side like for example a lot of them
are big pop stars they use qualities and
skills that are actually life skills
that you need but things like that
aren't promoted I'm all about
celebrating celeb so watch out for that
if you think I should interview a
certain celebrity let me know if you
want to watch my interviews my first one
my first world what viral was with
Ariana Grande when she came to the UK
for the first time I treated her like a
star and yeah I'm working on my
one-to-one interviews
I also stream on Twitch
um follow my Instagram to see my fat
body in a bikini uh
I'm Pro body positivity I just think
that you should love yourself while
still aiming to be the best version of
yourself you can be and there's nothing
wrong with that yeah uh John Bernard
catch me on all socials Tick Tock
Instagram YouTube John Bernard k j o n
Bernard K uh from Australia just a
content creator my final thoughts being
fat is unhealthy and we should stop it
we should do everything we can to stop
it uh big fan of the show Pearl thank
you for having me on it's a pleasure
coming all the way from Australia uh to
London so appreciate you having me and I
thought it was a good conversation good
dialogue thank you it was really
Pleasant yeah so um
Instagram name is kadeem868 that's k h i
know k-a and final thoughts I just think
that again you you live in your body
before you live on land
um you can change
and also there's always support there's
all there's always guidance if you need
support you need guidance seek it
if you were stressing about it just
Google you could ask Google questions
it's going to give you all the answers
you need
um just want to say big up to regen
London then create and we just open up
uh we're having our grand opening on the
3rd of July make sure to come out anyone
from South London big up come down to
our opening and uh yeah that's it
yeah you can find me on all Social Work
dot Works
um
I thought all together you should need
to prioritize everything you can't
really be put in your mental health
behind your physical health they both
need to be balanced in all of this you
always need to find a balance in both
but again your physical health will
affect your mental health so assuring
you have the balance really and having a
happy healthy life
so we do have a couple super chats um to
end the show adventurous filmmaker says
11 A.M tomorrow Mark Rose I went on PS
socials and she does look great in a
bikini life should be lived now not
later adventurous filmmaker high protein
10 000 steps vitamin D calorie deficit
multiply
low weight by 12 to start with your
calorie intake adventurous filmmaker
again enter black dragon I agree that
the body comes before the mind when you
are trying to lose belly going to the
gym won't work
um it's starting to by changing your
eating
puffy Vegas cardiologist told me 20
years ago there's only two things you do
drink lots of water and 10 000 steps a
day everything else you don't like so
much
um diet stress Etc Adam's son this is my
collection of nickels for each one of
stevia's of stevia Puffs excuses okay B
moss in five minutes you get muscle pain
you can tell bruh hasn't picked up a
weight for real and on Pia Blossom is
the best thing to happen to this podcast
you should be invited on more often
denalva Genova denalva uh biggie has
said it best four in the back two if you
fat puffy Vegas OB is a terrible please
do some research Dragon stallion uh
Pearl can we drop the three on the couch
and the three trainers in a forest for
three months and see which group fares
better acid lazy POS oh it hurts Dr
David Baker according to the Journal of
environmental medicine the reasons why
poor uh people in Western countries are
fatter compared to third world countries
or high unemployment lower education
level and lack of physical activity AKA
welfare cases uh Mr uh B
down um down another term to add oh damn
another I read that one uh Let me
refresh it really quick before we end
the show just to make sure I didn't miss
sunny also guys seriously like the video
on your way out uh a like is free so I
do not all you people that just watch
and don't like get get it to a thousand
likes on your way out like the video
um also leave a comment let me know do
you think body positivity is a good
thing or a bad thing sign up to our
Google form um for events in London
um also you know former show guests
might be there so your fan favorites
will come to our meetups in London
um like the video on your way out
subscribe to the channel and I'll talk
to you next time
what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things YouTube channel and welcome to
the pregame yo what's going on people
King rich is back again with another
podcast good evening and hi and welcome
to Auntie Jenny's video channel Jenny's
podcast it's your boy The Fresh Prince
of someone
coffee free for four months okay I gotta
say that how could everyone have someone
out there for them when there's more
women than men like I'm not saying you
have to be submissive to every old waste
man walking around I'm just saying that
it would be femininity would be in your
nature breaking it is to find somebody
you're compatible with that you'd like
not just of your same generation and
that likes the same things that you do
going out having fun get out okay okay
then then get out then get out don't be
faster then get out I'm not here to get
canceled today most men want a woman
that has some degree of femininity where
they feel like they're taken care of
taking care of I'm 99 I'm submissive and
you'll be surprised because I will say
what I want to say now and I'll say well
I want to say with my mind but my
demeanor doesn't change and I'm going to
look down on him because at the end of
the day whoever you're with is a
reflection of you what has happened in
society that has made the normal man a
waste man I I feel so bad asking a guy
to buy like a three thousand dollar bag
foreign
[Music]